Boom,
Jamie's fast today.
Damn.
How are you brother?
I'm going to see you,
man.
What's up man?
How you been?
I've been good.
Glad to be back.
D was the last time you were here was
after all the cars be craziness or
before?
No,
it was last time I was here.
Was In 2014,
early 2014.
It was before March 24.
Two.
Damn.
You got it.
I was doing the press for live from
Chicago,
my last special.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
What was that on?
That was on comedy central,
but we're getting it on Netflix.
It advanced or this special.
Me Too.
I'm doing.
I'm doing that flux now from now on.
Yeah.
It's just so easy.
It's easy for people to get.
They can watch it wherever they can,
you know,
deck and find that month.
They can watch it the day of.
They can watch it months later.
It's wherever you can promote it
whenever it's just A.
I'm really excited for this.
Yeah,
no Netflix.
I'm.
I become a netflix junkie over the last
couple of months.
I always looked to as that narco show.
Have you seen narco saw the first
couple.
Pretty good.
God damn good show is really good stuff.
I'm seven,
seven episodes in and every episode I'm
white knuckling,
just grabbing the couch.
Like I gotta get back.
But yeah,
I watched the first couple and it was,
it was dealt with.
They have so much fucking money now.
They can do whatever they want and they
can make like tv shows that are like
movies.
Yeah.
Sort of like how hbo does,
you know.
Yeah.
They make some good stuff man.
And they're easy to work with two.
Who's the kid on your shirt?
Uh,
some,
you know,
I did an interview yesterday,
uh,
with this,
it was a thing for vice and so she gave
me some,
some shirts.
She brought me some shirts from the
store.
She had got them for free or whatever.
And so this is just my favorite shirt
out of the three,
just a cute little kid.
Just
it looked like it could maybe be me.
That's what I sorta like high and it
could be given maybe a little bit.
The other shirts I did,
it was one other shirt.
It was a,
a woman pulling down,
like it was a sketch of a woman pulling
down her pants,
standing over a dog.
That's a bit weird.
And then there's another one that it's
had the tech set,
young Republican,
and then it was a person in a,
in a Klan outfit.
And I'm like,
all right,
I get what you're going for,
but I'm still not rocking.
So this was the winter out of the three.
That one that's wearable.
That's a cute kid.
Yeah.
No young Republican.
Stop.
Yeah,
stop.
Everybody stop.
Um,
so what,
what has it been like,
man,
this you sunk the Cosby,
raped,
shipped.
I mean,
I didn't expect to still be talking
about it now I saw you in January of
last year at a UFC.
Uh,
and yeah,
so I didn't expect it to still be.
It's not about me,
you what I mean,
but people made it.
It's just about.
I did a joke and,
and,
and people kind of rare,
but it's not really.
Has nothing to do with you.
It's not about me at all.
But uh,
that's,
that makes the story better for people.
But it's not a is not about me because
that's a good way of putting it.
It makes the story better.
They'd make it.
Makes the.
Yeah.
He's like,
oh,
he said it,
but it's like everybody was saying it.
But it is strange though that just you
saying it on stage for whatever reason,
it getting into a video and then all of
a sudden everybody was like,
yeah,
is that shit true?
Because everybody had heard about it.
It was one of those things that
everybody had kind of heard,
like you had heard rumors,
but it was never anything like concrete,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden,
oh yeah,
that was the match that lit the fire.
You know,
what really what really,
uh,
people forget about this part of it
because I remember being,
I was on tour in November 2014.
I remember being on my tour bus and,
and that he put out this thing.
Cosby meme.
Yes.
And then he,
it,
it actually had died down a little bit.
This was,
let's say November
10th,
this 12 fish around that range.
And he put out cause me,
me,
and you could go on his site and
different images and then people started
saying stuff about it and then that's
what made it take off again.
People forget about that really.
And it's actually because I remember
that being like Google analytics about
it.
Where peaked for a little bit in mid
October,
somebody show and then it dipped and
then the causeway meme is what set it
back off again.
The Internet is so fascinating.
Yeah.
Because nobody knows how to manage that
kind of shit.
Like if you're like a PR person,
there's nothing you can do.
First of all,
whoever did the meme thing,
I'm convinced that the dude who did what
I would imagine whoever did the main
thing was probably somebody works on his
website,
right?
Yeah.
So somebody works on his website is like
a web culture person.
Someone who understands the Internet.
Some tech dude or woman at tech person
is going to know what the fuck is going
to happen when they do that.
I almost think they did it on purpose.
That's my conspiracy theory.
Yeah.
I think they thought he was a piece of
shit and they said,
look,
I got an idea.
I don't know man.
That's what it was.
It's definitely weird,
but I'm trying to,
you know,
move on,
move on.
And I mean,
it's not his,
uh,
his is as I continue to is not really
about me,
you know,
I talk about the reaction to it in my
speech because it was really a crazy.
It was stressful too just to be in the
just casually,
you know,
going on social media or going on a site
how I normally would.
And then just seeing my name,
you know what I mean?
Now looking for it,
like Gnats,
googling myself but just go onto a site
and I was like,
Oh shit.
Yeah.
And originally,
initially at least people were mad at
you.
Yeah,
some still are really?
that's crazy.
People just,
they like,
yeah,
they,
they think I'm part of a,
it's,
it's a small amount of people like vocal
but vocal online.
So it seems like it's more.
Do you see that Bob Dude thinks that the
earth is flat?
Yeah.
There's a lot of fucking strange people
out there,
but that's one of the big conspiracies
was that bill cosby was trying to buy
NBC and that they didn't want bill cosby
to buy NBC.
So they came out with all these.
Yeah.
Fake charges.
Yeah,
and then they gave me a road.
They gave me my own TV show and reward.
Yeah,
they gave you a TV show,
but you already had the TV show that I
had to deal in in mid 2014.
Luckily you're a very funny,
talented guy so this isn't going to fuck
you over and it was fun.
I could like as far as leaning into it,
dude,
like dozens and dozens of media requests
that I didn't do good.
I came to my place one in looking at,
been on the road for a couple of weeks.
I'll come back to my apartment.
It's an inside edition.
Business cards slipped under my door.
It got into my building as if I would
come home.
Oh,
inside the district?
Yeah.
I'm gonna go on there now.
They're very resourceful for getting
into my building.
But uh,
that's creepy.
It was,
it was really creepy,
like people getting my cell phone out of
nowhere there you want to come in and
talk about a job.
It's like,
Eh,
no,
but um,
yeah,
just how good bob thanks to world is
flat
with Neil Neil degrasse Tyson.
So he wrote a dis song.
Did you hear this?
Oh I can't bring myself the song is
because Bob is a pretty.
It's funny because the song,
even though it's full of fallacies and
runs the song sounds good.
And then Neil degrasse Tyson,
his nephew or somebody who's also in the
science,
he put out a song and his song sounds
garbage but it has the facts in it,
but it sounds horrible,
horrible rap voice.
His voice sounded like,
is this guy rapping?
This guy can teach me something.
He could do a youtube video about why,
you know,
mintos explode in a goddamn coke color,
but I don't want to hear this guy rap.
It was horrible.
So it was weird.
That's unfortunate.
But truth gets a shitty voice.
Internet is weird,
man.
I wonder how much,
if Bob really believed that if he just
just cause strategy,
the people know how to manipulate
people.
You just say you could say something
contrary in an empirical response.
That's,
I mean that's the nature of when you
know,
people,
like I got fans that say,
and you probably had to say with fans
will just be like,
fuck you,
you piece of shit and you're like,
what's going on man?
He's like,
I'm a huge fan.
I just wanted to get your attention.
That does have.
And so one.
If it's the same thing with like Bob,
I know this will get people go and
because out of nowhere he doesn't tell
you.
I mean I haven't checked his history,
but I don't know if he has posed any
other scientific theories outside of
this,
but out of nowhere he's like,
you know what?
I'm about to post 10 tweets about the
world potentially being flat.
It's like,
ah,
I think he just wanted.
But there's a lot of people that believe
it.
That's what's fucked up Tila Tequila.
But I mean,
come on when it's,
when it,
you said to us Akila when's the last
time you said Tila?
Tequila?
Before she said the world is flat.
That's true.
That's here.
Tequila popped off my space.
Yeah.
We did a gathering of the Juggalos the
same year.
You did the gathering of the Juggalos
gathering of the Juggalos in 2010.
How was that?
It went.
Well.
I just did.
I did it for the stories and just for
the experience and,
and because they offered me more for one
show that anybody that was offered to me
at that time
till Tequila did porn.
Yeah.
She did a good job.
Good job.
She got,
she got potential in that market.
I went to the AVN.
Oh,
did you?
Yeah.
What's that like this year?
I just went,
yeah,
I went this weekend in Vegas.
How was it?
It was interesting.
I went and just walk the convention
floor.
At first I was a little bit trying to
um,
play.
I was actually was self conscious about
Vietnam.
It's just bad.
Is it like not a good look for me to be
here,
so people that's going to take pictures
like,
no man,
you didn't see me here.
Oh,
you told people know,
people know.
But then afterwards I loosened up and
the ship,
it was just,
you know,
talk to some porn stars and just
interesting vibe and walking around the
convention floor.
I felt comfortable being amongst other
creeps.
Everybody's Gawking and
uh,
it was,
it was fun though,
man.
Sat in the front row at the awards.
Did you really?
Yeah.
Next to Dana.
Dr Maran.
Oh yeah.
I Know Dana and Ron.
Jeremy was to the left to her than some
other porn lady was next to me.
And then Lexington still in me.
I think I was the only non porn person
in the first few rows.
I didn't.
Doug Benson,
was that somewhere?
Oh,
I'm that blowing his bought up
obviously.
No,
I'm sure everybody knows he's a creeper,
but it was not in the best way.
It was an interesting vibe,
man.
Just,
you know,
he's walking out with rockwood around
with test it out and it was a.
yeah,
it's weird,
right,
because everybody loves sex.
I mean sex is what.
It's one of the favorite things that
people do.
Yeah.
But the idea of filming it,
there's something fucking real taboo
about it.
Real locked down and taboo and,
and even like the admission that you
enjoy it is controversial.
Right?
Even though it's a multibillion dollar
business still with his own award show,
so it's definitely still a moment.
Billion dollar business and it's all
free now.
That's what's fucked up about it because
it used to be a multibillion dollar
business and it made sense because they
were selling dvds,
but now the multibillion dollar
businesses mostly paper view in hotel
rooms.
Oh,
that's where they make a lot of money
to.
One time I was playing xannies and St
Charles,
which is about good gig.
It's a outside of Chicago.
Yeah,
about 45 minutes,
an hour or so.
And so,
you know,
if I had a car I would have just went to
the Gig and went home every night,
but I didn't have a car so I got a ride
out there and I stayed there for the
weekend.
I remember I didn't have a laptop,
I didn't own a laptop at a time,
it was like 2007 or some shit to the
other.
And so,
um,
I was like,
I gotta order some hotel porn,
but the stuff I kept ordering,
I ordered,
it was soft porn,
so it was showing no penetration and no
anything.
It was just the grind it and this
fucking sucks.
I ordered another one and it was still
soft poop it.
I ordered a third one,
soft porn just spent 10 bucks a pop on
south point and I kind of wanted to
go to a call the front desk and be like,
these movies aren't what I thought they
were,
but I just,
I just ate the chart.
That's how it used to be in hotel rooms.
They'd show no penetration and they'd
showed no cum shots.
Yeah,
yeah.
They would show like scenes of people on
top of it didn't.
Bill Hicks used to have a bit about it.
You Bill,
Bill Hicks,
you save a bit about hotel porn,
about [inaudible].
They used to do apparently the way they
used to film scenes as they would film a
hardcore scene and a softcore version,
so they would have like soft core scenes
where they shot angles where they knew
you couldn't see anything and they did
it specifically just for for hotel rooms
like those,
all those hotel chains,
like the marriotts and all those.
Those are the biggest porn sellers in
the world.
You don't think about it,
but they're all in the porn business.
They make a fuck load of money off of
porn because they're charging now.
How much is it now?
Like 20 bucks or something?
Probably.
I haven't looked in a long time.
I know I go on the Internet and looked
at that stuff.
I think it's like 20 bucks or somewhere
close,
so I guess that's the move you want to
watch porn on tv if you,
if you want a big screen,
but sometimes you can't even reride now
knows that's a problem.
Yeah.
Or pause.
Yeah,
it's a very restricted.
What do you think,
because I got.
The thing about this at the,
at the awards was they had awards for
everything.
It's just best director.
What do you.
What makes a good porn director?
I feel like I could direct.
I think.
I think I could jump into porn direct
and kind of easy.
It was just if you just give me 12 hours
to watch a bunch of different porn,
give me the point and gave me the
screeners for the best director
nominees.
I was like,
I could mimic what they do within my
third directed.
Well you gotta think
not a whole lot to it because it's just
sex.
It's not like a direct in some car chase
on a bridge and as a fucking monster
coming after the people.
Now this is a real simple.
It's just fucking so.
Yeah.
But if you talk to the porn people,
they take that shit super serious.
I wrote a piece on my blog a long time
ago about a porn party because I had a
buddy that I used to do Jujitsu with who
is a director for a porn company and he
held a party for the release of this
film that he made that he was.
It was like an art film and what he
wanted to do was make a real movie with
a real plot and real dialog,
but have people fucking it and we,
we didn't know what it was,
was just a bunch of guys from Jujitsu
invited us to the party.
We all went,
what the fuck is going on here?
So they have this projection screen and
they start playing the scenes.
So they play this movie and he gets out
there and he's talking about it.
Like they said this couldn't be done.
That said that what I was doing was just
the industry wouldn't accept it,
but I did it.
I'm here and not the porn people.
This is backward.
Porn made money.
We're talking like early 2000,
2001 or something like that.
So then
like we're watching the scene right?
This seems ridiculous.
This is asked to mouth seen.
There's dudes banging this,
his chicken the ass then fucking her
mouth and she's making these,
he's gagging noises.
Like
then someone says she's here in his car,
pulls up and the girl gets out,
the girl who's in the scene and she gets
out with a dude and the dude gets out,
looks at the screen,
looks at her,
raises his hand like this.
And she's like.
And he's like,
you know,
he's a,
he's making these like we can't see what
he's saying.
And he's like,
Whoa,
why didn't you tell me?
And she's like,
I was gonna I was gonna tell you.
And so we're like,
do you think that he didn't know that
she was a porn star?
Like,
do you think he didn't know,
maybe he didn't know.
So we had to figure it out.
Right?
So I go,
hey man,
I go,
come here for a second.
So the dude comes over and I go,
did you not know that,
uh,
that she was going to be in film?
He goes,
dude,
I thought she was a hairdresser.
I go,
come on.
He goes,
yeah,
she told me she does hair,
dressing and makeup.
Are you fucking kidding me?
And she took him to this party.
She took him there.
She lied.
She met him at like some some bar.
How long ago?
How long before the party?
I think like the day before.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I mean Shit,
all of them.
Shit,
that's true.
That's true.
She tried.
She tried to show him what she's capable
of,
what he could have.
I wish I knew specifically how long they
knew each other.
I don't think it was very long.
I think was real sleek.
She's trying to show him what's up I
guess and just try to surprise him.
It was more like,
hey look what the fuck.
I'm up to some of that.
But he came at the right time because it
was just asked mouth ass mouth.
The way I describe it was like the
dude's ball slapping against her ass was
like to chalk erasers,
like chocolates
and then he would go from that to our
mouse over
and that's right where homeboy walked
in,
got out of the car and was like,
what in the fuck?
I got pictures of them together.
I got pictures of him and us.
It's all online.
You can find it on.
Um,
her name,
her name is Jia poloma.
It was like a famous porn star back in
the day.
I think she's since retired.
So short life,
those young gals,
they.
It's not like something you could do,
like Meryl Streep deep into your
fifties.
Well,
this,
I'm Nina Hartley because she's still
doing.
She,
I saw her at the convention.
She had a long line of people waiting
for her.
She's a rare one.
A rare one.
Especially for girls.
Right?
Yeah,
she's odd though,
man.
She did.
Kevin Pereira was podcasts and I was
there for a little bit because I just
happened to be.
It was at the,
at the Ice House and get me sit in with
her for a little bit,
but she was talking about how it went.
Whatever she fucks.
She doesn't just make people wear
condoms.
She makes people wear gloves.
What do you put?
Oh,
you found the pictures?
Yeah.
She doesn't say this is all true.
Oh,
that's true.
That's the girl.
That was the.
What's the caption?
I don't know,
man.
Just to do.
And the little.
Not even that hot.
That's not my.
No,
that's from a cliff notes.
Oh,
this.
You talked about it on one before.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well there's a blog.
The blog should still be up on my
website.
I found it on a bodybuilding message
board.
Someone like copy and paste the whole
blog.
Follow up with them at all.
Any.
Any,
any update?
No,
but I did run into the dude one day at
Chipotle,
a [inaudible] like way back in the day.
We're not one of them Mexican joint,
but it was,
but that,
that is 100 percent true little fresh
face.
Young Fella.
He looked like a,
just a,
you know,
innocent young kid from the valley,
had no fucking idea.
He was a nice guy.
He,
he had a great sense of humor.
I'll tell you that man,
because he was definitely dumbfounded by
the experience,
but laugh and a lot.
He was laughing.
He wasn't upset.
Like,
Damn.
I was gonna marry
him.
Laughing,
laughing.
It wasn't like nervous.
Well,
there was bolts.
We'll shoot.
You know,
it's,
that's not a good picture of her.
She's attractive girl.
You probably thought,
hey,
this girl's cool man.
We're going to get our free guns.
Meanwhile,
slap,
ticky.
Ticky probably still went for it.
I couldn't.
Could be.
You never know.
You never know how to.
Weird conversation with a dude who is
there too because he was a male porn
star and was talking very serious about
how he has to keep his edge.
And I was like,
what do you mean?
So you gotta keep your edge.
You got to,
you can't,
can't relax when you're on the set and
you got to keep your edge.
And I go,
well,
what do you mean by that?
He's like,
you got to always be ready to fuck.
Go.
Always be ready.
Like want to go?
Like right now I'm like,
really?
Like that's how you like you,
like on the set,
sort of like there's probably suck.
Get caught.
Yeah.
I mean some mental stuff too.
That man,
of course this is pre Viagara yeah.
When we're talking about 2000,
2001,
I don't think they had Viagra back then.
I really don't think they did.
I don't know what type of stuff they say
to themselves in their head what it went
back down.
But let's find out.
Find out when they invented Viagara.
Jamie back was,
I feel like nineties,
mid nineties
and then.
Yeah,
I feel like Friday night 98 ish a look
at you fucking nailed it.
Twenty seven slash 98.
Jesus Christ.
Hannibal.
Good.
Are you,
how did you nail it?
Like that?
I just remembered been,
I just remember the stories in
highschool and shit around it.
I just remember it being,
you know,
uh,
everybody was making those late night
jokes about it.
Oh,
that's true,
right?
That same joke.
Yeah.
The overnight get the director for five
hours,
call a doctor.
I was another girl.
A call that up.
Yeah.
That's one of those jokes that nobody
could say they got ripped off that.
That was a joke.
They fucking everybody did.
What is your take on all this?
Amy Schumer?
Shit.
I don't know.
I've been looking at it.
I don't think she would take jokes.
I don't think she will take and a lot of
jokes that
they've been talking about like that.
Have you seen the most recent ones?
Was the most one?
It was a gang of them.
They put together some compilations.
There's a few of them that are there.
Definitely suspicious,
but the problem is when you're looking
like this,
you know when you like go and scouring
all the hours of standup that I'm sure
she's done places you can find similar
premises and she'll like that.
I think the real issue is whoever wrote
for the sketch show,
whoever wrote those sketches,
at the very least there's an originality
problem at the very least,
but there's.
There's,
there's like,
like the Kathleen Madigan one is a real
egregious one because you could totally
come up with the same idea that Kathleen
Madigan had about someone slapping food
out of your mouth.
As a matter of fact,
someone said I think should fear said
that that used to be on the flintstones.
So there was an episode of the
flintstones where Fred was trying to
lose weight and so we had like a robot
that would slap food out of his mouth or
something along those lines.
You see if you could find that.
But um,
but the fact that it was the same two
bits back to back like Kathleen had that
and Kathleen had,
you know,
I would hire somebody.
Kathleen Madigan's bit was about Oprah.
How Oprah so rich.
Like how could she be so fat if I was
that rich,
I'd have people slap food out of my
mouth.
I would hire someone to,
to exercise me while I slept like a baby
with cerebral palsy.
So yeah.
And then so they go from the slap thing
right to the exercise.
You while you're asleep,
back to back.
It's,
it's too close.
Then there was this one from college
humor that was a,
a,
a sketch about the audition for two
girls,
one cup,
and it's exact same setup.
The,
I mean the fucking Fred.
Oh,
look at that.
See he's got a,
like someone.
He hired someone to knock food out of
his mouth.
Yeah.
Like that's not the most original idea.
Like people thought that before.
The real problem is they're back to back
the same thing.
Back to back.
Yeah.
Then there's this,
uh,
the college humor one,
which is the fucking exact same setup
there in the office.
They're a,
they're going through the audition
process for two girls.
One Cup.
I mean it's the same fucking thing and
there's a couple of other ones.
So it,
there's an originality problem with
somebody you know,
and I didn't know that college humor
bit.
So like say if I was doing a sketch show
and someone came to me what we were
doing,
the sketch show and said,
hey,
how about we do a sketch about the
audition process for two girls,
one cup.
I'd be like,
that's fucking great.
Yeah.
What do we do?
How we do it,
so she might not have had any knowledge
at all that there's other bits existed.
Like there's so much content out there
today to be aware of.
Every premise in every bit is almost
impossible.
It's tough man.
And it was,
I tried to,
when I was doing my show,
I would get pitched stuff and,
and uh,
I will try to.
Adam,
no,
all comedy obviously,
but sometimes I think like I would try
to remember the stuff,
but you can't remember everything,
you know,
in a day I think we kicked people from
in living color out of the comedy store
I should say.
We had nothing to do with it.
But when I was there,
like the comics were complaining so
much.
So they got him kicked out.
Actually I had nothing to do with it,
but I remember like being like,
wow,
this is cool.
They kicked the writers out because they
had these writers that would come and
they would hang out at the,
in the back of the comedy store.
And then they would,
those sketches would appear on
television,
like they would take people's premises
and turned them into sketches.
It was a real problem.
Was like,
this is in the nineties,
the early nineties.
Yeah.
And um,
so it has happened in my friend Kevin
Genius showcase
for all these writers.
And he did this bit about muffins.
He used to have this closing bit that he
should do about muffins,
that if someone wants a piece of your
Muffin,
you don't give them the muffin top,
you can have all the muffins teams.
He,
uh,
had a bit that he did.
He had a showcase for NBC at development
deal with NBC stump you want but you
can't fight.
It was a funny bit.
And in with Kevin,
he's a funny guy,
you know.
And Kevin is an,
I mean,
first of all,
his bit was way before the Seinfeld
episode,
but I mean he's not a thief at all.
So then that bit came out like in the
exact form on an episode of Seinfeld and
this is NBC writers who went to see him
live.
That shit happens all the time.
Those guys have to produce and some of
them aren't that good.
I've had fucking,
I've had some development deals with
writers and or some development deals.
And then you meet with writers and you
read some of the stuff they write and
these guys had.
This is in the nineties,
right?
So this is like the sitcom boom friends
and shit.
This is when I was on news radio and
these guys had big deals where they were
getting a lot of money and they were
fucking garbage.
Terrible writers,
terrible.
And they get,
they get desperado man and they need
premises and they'll go to comedy clubs.
No fucking steel.
And it was a huge problem.
It's been a huge problem for a long
time.
So.
So you take away those sketches and you
go,
well,
you know,
I don't necessarily think you can make
her responsible for those sketches
because there's no way.
Like if you were going to do your show
and you had a premise that somebody
pitched you,
what are you gonna do?
You're gonna go online and say,
Hey,
has anybody heard this premise before?
You're not going to do that.
Uh,
you've,
you have to ask around your friends and
your friends might not know.
You could ask me and I've been doing
standup for 26 fucking years.
I might not know.
You might ask 10 people and those 10
people don't know.
But then that big guts on television,
someone goes,
Jesus Christ,
I saw that on mad TV.
That was another one.
There was a mad tv one,
there was a mad TV tv one.
It was the exact same premise.
It was about a woman.
It was about amy talking to a woman at
the counter of a store and someone had
helped her.
The person who helps her gets
commissioned and she couldn't say it was
a black guy.
So she was trying a way to say it
without saying it's a black guy.
She's like,
um,
he had dark eyes.
Um,
you know,
and like it's put the same exact premise
as mad TV.
Right.
Did she know about the manatee viewing
the fuck watched mad TV.
I never watched it.
If you ever watch it,
I watched some of it,
but not maybe twice,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean how they were on for 100 years,
man.
TV was on forever.
Like how could you.
I like the sketches.
I didn't realize how racist it was when
I was watching it.
But the nail lady sketch.
That's a good sketch that made that girl
no.
Nat Bunk.
The Bunk Quique we.
Oh No,
I was telling them about the one,
the lady that ran the nail shop.
Uh,
Angela Johnson.
No,
no,
no.
This was early.
I think this is even before Angela
Johnson was on the show.
This was like early in mad TV.
It was one of their signature sketches
to.
Yes.
I forget what her catchphrase was.
Man.
I'm getting old man.
I don't remember shit anymore.
Do you smoke weed?
Occasionally.
That's probably the occasionally,
but not know nat.
I definitely don't smoke as much as you
and a,
you some Alpha brain.
So
we're out of here.
I'll give you.
I got.
I got instant.
Okay.
Can I keep this shit handy?
This is without this.
I'm Ricardo.
I smoke.
I sometimes it's,
but it has to be the last thing that I
do.
I really,
I can't be out and about like I can't
smoke and do an interview.
Really?
Yeah.
That's my favorite way to do interviews
because I can't,
I,
uh,
I did this thing a snoop dogg has this
turfed up like,
oh yeah,
I did it a Monday and uh,
just
he had shot what episode as I got there.
I'm supposed to be on the second
episode,
his producer,
he's about it,
trying to wrangle them so he could,
we could start shooting my segment.
He just leaves for 45 minutes.
So I go into the trailer.
He has a legitimate,
is a half pound bag of weed
and so he,
he's welcome to download.
I can't smoke with y'all man.
It'd be a totally different interview.
Let me get out of there before I catch a
contract.
But he didn't,
he just did a whole show in a panel
show.
How fucking high as fuck
though.
Actually you expect it.
But it's still amazing when you see it.
I mean obviously I know,
but he's just like,
yeah,
he's just,
you know,
talking shit,
holding court,
cracking jokes.
Funny.
Like he's like,
he is like you when you're around him.
Like yeah,
that's,
it was motherfuckers star operates like
a star,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Snoop's a bad motherfucker.
He works his ass off.
I'm sure.
So many shows.
Shit.
Yeah.
He's always got something going on.
Then the tour and still dj gigs.
Three different web series and shit.
So what is he doing?
Things,
things on youtube or something like
that.
I think this is going to be on youtube.
Yeah.
So anyway,
back to the Amy Schumer thing.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know man.
It's not good.
But it's also this,
there's like this momentum that's a part
of it now.
It's like a feeding frenzy.
Yeah.
You know,
and you got like Ari Shaffir had
something like that.
Remember when those people were mad at
him because he did a bit and one of his
specialist about a girl with one arm and
everyone's mad at him.
He's sitting at the center name shows
name,
comedy central.
Shouldn't let them,
let them say her name.
Why the fuck would they don't know how
that slipped through the cracks because
when I,
um,
one of my specials I uh,
did a joke about my ex girlfriend was
ladies and gentlemen,
I talked about having an introduced my
ex girlfriend at an open mic after
because she was a poet.
I hadn't seen her.
She just Kinda goes to me and didn't
stop calling me.
So it was just.
The joke was,
ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome to the cold hearted bitch
broke my heart.
You may know her from that returning my
phone calls also given out mediocre Joe
blow jobs.
Please welcome to the stage blank,
blank.
And.
But I was a,
it was a couple times I would say her
name on stage and they were like,
you have to change the name.
What I'm.
I changed it to something that's close
to the name,
but they were adamant about I had to
change it.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened.
I think they didn't see the problem is
he didn't make that special for them.
He made that special on his own and sold
it to comedy central.
So I think comedy central just bought it
and they didn't have to do any work,
so they just bought it and then edit it
and then someone just didn't do their
job
that.
So it was like,
thanks.
It was a fat person smelled.
It was just
very angry named mostly unknown person.
I was like,
God damn heart,
her name is.
I was like,
that's her full name.
Yeah,
that was rough.
While you live,
you learn.
We all make mistakes.
But what he was saying was that there
was a fire and you just got to stay
away.
Just let it burn out.
Yeah,
let that fire burn out.
Right.
You know,
and I think there's a fire right now
after her and a lot of it is,
look,
you got to be honest about what's
happening in her life.
She's a movie star now.
All of a sudden
had one of the biggest years never in a
that a comedian to seven.
Yeah.
So she went from a year and a half ago
to someone who would do.
Well she probably sell out a weekend in
Phoenix or some shit.
You know what I mean?
Like she did well,
right?
She was sued theaters.
I think she was just doing okay.
So let's say theater.
She's doing like a 1500 seat or
something like that.
Now she's doing 20,000 seats.
She's doing arenas,
man.
She's doing arena tours.
So there's got to be.
Some of it is the tall poppy syndrome,
right?
To people want to knock her down because
she's taken off so high.
But objectively stay away from that.
Look it up,
look at the whole thing objectively.
There's an originality problem.
One hundred percent.
There's definitely an originality
problem.
The problem is whose problem is that?
You know,
like here's,
here's,
here's something that someone said.
Someone said she's put out 15 hours of,
uh,
of sketches in one year.
Of course there's going to be some,
some originality problems.
What,
what,
what about that show?
Key and Peele
peele key and peele show like an old man
on purpose.
Watch it.
I watched it.
I don't even know how to say.
Key name key.
A pellet plants doing sketch comedy,
Peele,
key and Peele.
Those guys are fucking hilarious.
And really original.
Really original.
They do some crazy shit you ever seen
that bit?
They do about slap pass about the guy
who slaps acids and the locker room.
He's got an addiction to slap in the
ass.
I haven't seen that.
It's fucking funny man.
And it's some shit that I've never seen
before.
Like whenever I see one of their
sketches,
it's always so out there and weird and
fun into a very dark direction a lot of
times too.
Yeah.
But original has.
Fuck,
it's all original.
So like that show's been on for years
and no one's,
no one's coming at them for,
for not.
So it can't,
it's not just the tall poppy syndrome.
There's definitely an issue and it
sucks,
man.
It sucks to watch all the blood in the
water,
you know,
it's,
it sucks to see like her big moment.
All this great shit happened to her and
all of a sudden now it's all this chaos.
Uh,
I mean,
I think it's just more,
it's one of those things which seems
like it's a crazy,
but isn't that as crazy because we,
just to say we deepen it with deep edit.
It as our world,
you know what I mean?
Maybe like my,
my mom.
Is it like,
hey,
didn't you.
That's what it is big.
It is to be your mom.
It hasn't found out yet.
It's only been around for a week.
Yeah,
I mean it's still only been going on for
a week.
This is approved fresh thing.
I mean think about like when like that
caused me video came out,
that fucking dude was still doing giant
theaters.
He was doing like 10,000 seat places
within a year.
All that shit was over.
Like,
you know,
people don't like when they find out a
comedian's a plagiarist,
they don't like it.
They get angry.
And I think someone wrote an article
about this recently,
you,
uh,
you tweeted it and who was the guy that
wrote the article?
But the guy had a real good point and he
said if someone does something in a
movie and it turns out that,
that,
that scene had been in another movie
like,
Oh,
you stole that from blazing saddles or
some shit.
That doesn't offend people because they
know that you're just reading some lines
from a movie,
but if someone goes to see Hannibal,
they know that your shit is your
thoughts like they,
they want to see what is Hannibal?
Think about this,
you know,
when I go see Hannibal buress,
what,
what is,
what are his thoughts on blank?
You know,
what,
how does he feel about this?
How does he feel about.
I expect that,
you know,
you're an interesting,
intelligent guy.
You're going to have your own point of
view like you go to see.
Bill Burr is a perfect example.
Bill Burr.
You can count on bill burke,
kind of humor from Bill Burr,
like you go see him.
He's got like that.
Betty did about Arnold Schwartzenegger.
Oh great man.
Like you ever see that bed?
Is it a bit about a is fucking gold
digging?
We've got an epidemic of gold digging
whores.
She took down a great man.
He's a great man.
It's,
it's such a bill burr bit.
I fucking love that bit,
but my point is you're not going to get
anybody to write that for you.
He's not going to steal that from
somebody that's.
It's so obvious when you see the bit
that it's his sense of humor and when
you're not doing that,
when you doing just a bunch of like
patchwork bullshit that some other
people wrote for you or some clunky
premises that you may or may not have
lifted from somebody else and reworded.
It offends people.
Yeah.
Because you're a faker.
Right?
So that's what happened with Mensa.
People were offended,
you know,
they found out it's fake.
You're fake and you're not.
You're not doing what you're saying
you're doing.
You're saying here's the world through
my eyes,
but it's not really the world through
your eyes.
You just,
you're just trying to push buttons and
Fucking Bang on things and make.
You're trying to make things happen.
You know,
you're trying to use bits that work.
You're not necessarily showing people
the way you think about stuff and I
think that's what's unique about standup
as opposed to anything else.
Like if you found out that Jay Z had
writers,
would it offend you?
I wouldn't offend me.
It wouldn't bother me at all if I found
out that,
you know,
the rolling stones hired some guy to
write their new album.
It's not,
I'm not offended,
but if I find out that Lucy case,
new special was written entirely by a
team of writers and you know,
and he,
you know,
just sort of like rehashed all the shit
that they wrote down.
Then I don't feel the same way when I
like when I watched Louis,
I know that I'm going to see Louis ck
thoughts on stuff.
Every time you see them,
you know that that's Louis thinking
about shit and it's so obvious when you
hear it on stage.
It's like it's coming from his voice.
So that's the difference I think.
Yeah.
Would stand up definitely.
What's the guy's name here?
Wow.
Okay.
That's not even a real person.
How dare you person whoever you are,
why joke thieves are bad by someone who
doesn't believe in intellectual
property.
Yeah.
Well,
I believe in intellectual property and I
definitely jokes if you.
Have you ever been swiped anybody's
swiped from you.
I've heard about it.
I hear about somebody.
I'm trying some that opened Mike,
it has been lines where maybe they took
that idea.
I think that certain things or
commercials and shit like that,
but I haven't really,
uh,
I take kind of portray [inaudible].
Patrice O'Neil had a philosophy about
that.
Like somebody take a joke for me then
that means they needed it way more than
I do and I'm just gonna write more jokes
because I got,
you could take I'm a right.
Alright.
20 more.
You know what I mean?
So I've seen,
I've heard about comics tryma shit or
trying or doing different things,
but I don't really engage it because
it's just like,
ah,
if you,
if you try my shit,
I'm probably gonna just,
you know,
good luck with it,
man.
The problem with that theory,
I know what if someone does it and they
become like men Sia,
they become huge and they do that shit
on television and then you're like,
what if it's like a bit.
That's something you have a very unusual
bit about fucking skittles.
It's like a signature pit and it's
hilarious whatever.
Pick a subject,
but it's like something that's really
near and dear to your heart and maybe
worked on it for a long time.
You know,
there's,
there's bits that you work on like the
day I don't fucking work right away and
try to figure out how to.
You figure out how to make them work and
then someone comes along and just swipes
it.
You're not going to just accept.
Well,
I guess that theory,
my theory applies to people what they
saw less famous than when they started.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
You just assume they're never gonna make
it,
but I don't know,
man.
It's a,
it's definitely dice.
I mean,
amy's a close friends.
Soda is dicey to exactly that.
That is just a weird,
weird.
Yeah.
Because I like her a lot.
I think she's hilarious.
She's very funny and sharp in interviews
and on the radio,
you know,
doing podcasts.
He's fucking funny.
She's sharp,
she's smart,
she's ambitious as fuck.
But this is a very unfortunate.
It's very unfortunate.
You know,
there's also a problem with,
uh,
apparently she burned through a shitload
of material doing that show,
like doing their show,
like a lot of her standup premises she
did in the show,
the show was very important and then
right afterwards just got to do the HBO
special,
you know,
and the,
and the HBO special.
There's only the one bit.
It was only the Wendy Liebman joke,
right?
Well there's a Mark Marin,
one to the bulb at the Mark Marin one
that people are saying.
It's like,
well that's a pretty obvious premise,
but you know,
I dunno man.
Who the fuck knows,
you know,
who knows?
It's not good that
that's it.
We'll leave it there,
leave it there.
It's not good.
She'll rebound because she's talented
and I really think she is.
But if she was anybody else though,
how about this?
This is true.
If I didn't care about her,
if I wasn't friends with her,
she was anybody else?
People would want her head if she was
some asshole,
you know,
like if it was seeing,
like if,
if it came out that car had a new show
and all this shit was on,
people would want his head,
there will be blood in the water,
but she's strong woman's feminists,
you know,
this whole deal.
Like it's like people are and people
like her,
like comics,
there's,
there's definitely a more kid gloves
approach from the comedy community
except for the girls that she stole from
or allegedly stole from or they believe
she stole from they.
They went after her and then they pulled
back like Wendy Liebman and Kathleen
Madigan.
They went after and then they pulled
back.
So is unfortunate.
Definitely.
Look at you,
be backed out of the whole conversation
back.
Pulled your chair,
vice chair back.
She'll be fine.
But you know,
that's why it's important to have
original material like Palae and Kiki.
What is the name key?
Keenan?
Keenan,
impale.
Writers.
Men.
Writers are a fucking problem.
If you don't know those dudes.
If you hire a bunch of writers,
you just don't know.
You don't know what their ethical
processes,
you don't know what their,
how their creative process works,
you know,
you don't know man.
Fucking and those guys have to produce,
right?
They have to produce.
I knew a girl who was a,
uh,
a writer on,
um,
she was a writer on like a,
a crime show or something like that and
she apparently had plagiarized some
shit.
She got busted,
you know,
she had just cut and pasted or came up
with some,
some shit that somebody else had already
done.
And that was it for her.
Later,
later in the season it might show,
uh,
so we know,
we'll send out,
I'll send out requests for jokes about a
certain thing.
And it was some writers,
you know,
eat subject.
They have to crank it up,
crank out 10 a bunch of jokes,
and he was one right close to the.
He just started just send in like one
week has joked.
It don't want to be like,
you,
uh,
I never said anything about it because
the season was winding down with a part
of me wanting to say,
are you depressed as
fuck?
Give me one joke,
one of I'm a bad boss because I didn't.
I didn't say step it up.
Yeah,
I knew him before,
but I want to put a comic.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
But he's a writer.
He wrote a lot too.
He was sitting in one like one joke.
The problem with comics is if I'm
working on your show and I come up with
a fucking bang as premise,
I'm going to Tuck that shit away and I'm
going to give you some half ass shit
because like,
if it's going to be in your act,
you're like,
oh,
holy shit,
this could be my new closer rescued.
Make me this.
Could be it.
I can't give this to an animal that
happens.
Right?
With comics,
I mean I could see it.
I can see it.
Avenue.
Fuck.
Yeah,
that's definitely what happens with
comics.
If you,
if you're a writer,
just a writer,
that's a different thing.
They didn't want to be known for your
writing.
Right?
But if you're a writer and a comic,
Tuck it,
tuck it.
It's just interesting,
man.
This whole thing is,
is
an interesting time because,
uh,
the accountability accountability is so
high now.
Yeah,
I think that's good.
I really do.
Because I think,
you know,
excuse amy and say it wasn't her fault
and you know,
it's all writers and everything like
that.
Whatever the.
Obviously there was an originality
problem obviously.
I mean there's no getting around that.
I think that's a good thing,
man.
It's his forces people to to be as
original as possible and even then
you're going to have some mistakes or
some parallel thinking.
Parallel thinking is so common,
like a Viagra thing,
right?
Like when you,
if you have an erection for more than
five hours,
seek medical help.
Dad Joke writes itself.
That's over.
That's,
that's,
you know,
everybody
thing I got,
I got two kids.
I've got a boy and a girl.
The boy is an idiot.
The girl is so sweet and smart boys
doing this dumb shit.
The girl is over there doing this.
Yup.
My wife is pregnant out.
I joke about wanting to have a kid just
so I can get 20 to 30 minutes of
material because then I get it with
that,
I get the uh,
I get the trying to get my girl pregnant
material.
Then the wife is pregnant material,
what's going on?
She's pregnant,
she's all of this shit.
Then I got the,
the delivery,
the delivery of the baby material,
like,
oh shit,
fellows,
if you'd let me tell you in there,
do not look at the pussy.
The pussy is going to be ruined.
That joke.
And then you get the having a newborn
baby.
It doesn't do anything.
It's just there,
blah,
blah blah.
And then you got all of the toddlers.
There's plenty of material in the jokes
have been done.
Dave been done.
There's no way around that.
There's no way around those.
There was a seat.
You do.
You remember in the early two thousands,
while Bush was still an office,
there was a Chinese fighter jet collided
with an American fighter jet and the
Chinese fighter jet pilot.
The pilot's name was Wong Way.
No.
Yes.
His name was Wong.
Way Long Way.
W E I
w o n g w e I
really?
Yep.
Oh Man.
That joke at the comedy store that night
should fear like it's tells about it
because he worked the door and the,
you know,
the comedy store starts at nine.
It goes till two.
You said guys who would go on at 11
didn't know that someone had already did
it at nine,
9:30,
10,
15 guys would show up five minutes
before they sat.
They have no idea.
They say it and the audience is like a
weekend and punk is the same fucking
joke over and over and over again.
I would love a DVD of that night that
pitching,
pitching guys,
pitching guys that had written.
Wow.
Lisa.
It was like,
Oh shit.
There's one way to
kill it.
I'm feeling creatively inspired.
One way guys have ever written a while
ago,
I got this one.
This is it.
Yeah.
Some road itself.
Sometimes I'll search a joke it before I
tweet something that's about something
topical.
I'll search that on twitter to see if
somebody else said it already.
That's a good move.
That's smart and it's some stuff where
I'm like,
oh,
because there's some stuff that's easy.
First thought that anybody can come up
with.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I'm not that creative.
I didn't have a hot take on this
cavaliers game,
but it's weird because it's your thought
like,
shouldn't you just express yourself?
You have to go looking to make sure
someone didn't express a similar idea
first.
You don't have to,
but it's just tricky.
I'd rather do that then.
Yeah.
Sweet.
The exact same thing as somebody 30
followers just tweeted.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's tricky.
Right?
And mediums,
man.
That was another one that Wendy Liebman
got pissed at.
Someone had taken one of her bits and
turned it into a meme,
but without her face.
So credit.
Yeah.
It was a car.
They used a cartoon image instead of,
um,
instead of her.
And uh,
she was pissed.
Yeah.
If it was her faith,
I mean if they'd done it a bunch of
times to me,
I'm sure to you too with your actual
face and a bit that you said,
I have zero problem with that.
I like it.
It's good.
It means they like you.
They think you're funny.
And they,
they took the time to say something that
you said that they enjoyed and they put
it in a picture.
I'm kind of upset that I never made blam
blam weeding him tee shirts.
Shit.
It's not too late.
Not too late.
Especially if I take you pig finding.
If I take you pig hunting then we can.
We can go out there and with them.
Yeah.
But people had that mean like
immediately,
like why we're doing the podcast bland,
Bland Wheaton Ham,
blam blam eating ham.
Like Dan was one of the big complaints
about that fat Jewish guy was that he
would take standup bits and they would
put them in memes.
They would steal someone's stand up
jokes and turned into a meme.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
you know,
and it became the single.
Is he stealing jokes because he's just
putting up memes on Instagram,
like what is that?
You know,
but yeah,
it is dealing jokes because he wasn't
crediting people and he was also taking
people's memes from their site and just
reposting it without crediting them and
then getting all of the new followers
and likes exactly somebody I went out
with this girl in New York who works
with his management or something.
And uh,
I don't know how true this is or if this
is just a one off instance,
but she said that he got booked to do
somebody prime or a sweet 16 and she
said he got a hundred $50,000.
I was like,
what?
It was a bar Mitzvah
event.
I was like,
what?
Well,
if you're some fucking hedge fund guy
and you've got a son who's really into
the Internet.
Yeah,
that's what he wants you to get me the
fat Jewish.
Alright son.
That's what you want.
That's what you'll get.
Because like beyonce will do gigs like
that.
And she'd go to Bahrain,
dance for some prints.
Yeah.
Make a couple million bucks at home on a
private jet.
They do shit like that.
Yeah.
They'll do people's parties.
I know a dude and uh,
at his party,
he's some insanely wealthy guy.
He had sting,
sting performed and someone else like
that,
like some other,
like big name dude.
And my friend went to this party and I
was like,
what the fuck was that?
Like?
They go,
dude,
we're watching sting performed for 50
people at this guy's house.
Like death.
Fucking crazy.
It's very crazy.
At Dana White's birthday party.
I'm stone temple pilots.
Played
Stone motherfucking temple pilots in a
small ballroom in Vegas at a hotel and
date.
I'll tell you what,
man,
that dude,
he's dead now.
He just died of a heroin overdose.
I guess we're just just fucking his body
up until it quit.
But I'm.
That mother fucker could perform.
Yeah,
I won.
It was,
there was maybe a.
nobody was paying attention.
Here's the part of the problem.
Yeah.
We had to get everybody up like we were
like,
people feel bad.
So they're like getting people up other
seats and getting them towards the
stage.
Watch this huge band is doing,
hey,
who the fuck knows how much they had to
pay them?
It must have been an ungodly sum of
money,
but I'm.
That fucking dude rocked out.
Like there was 100,000 people in that
audience.
He went full on.
I mean full on.
It was.
It was really impressive.
It made me want to be better at standup.
It made me want to work at my standup.
Was is easy.
I think it's easier to do that when
you're doing music because you got the
music.
Yeah.
You don't need momentum.
It helps me,
but it's easy to have the wind taken out
of your sails when you perform foot.
A inattentive crap,
like it's tough to just really get into
it.
I guess you can,
but it takes a different for doing
standup and doing stand up if you do it
in front of people that are.
Half of my eating,
10 of them I texted and a few people
paying attention and given polite
circles.
Like it's tough to be like,
okay,
I'm going to go all the way because
you're so dependent on it reacts a
little music.
You get through band behind you.
You can be like,
I'm going to rock this shit out.
And cassius checking,
that's true.
But in comedy acts with guitars too.
They could do the same shit.
Yeah.
And then they still need the labs.
The labs is what builds into,
into being able to really rock that
shit.
Yeah.
And be a pro.
But I found some that people if you,
because I've done some gigs that a
horrible.
I did this Gig so nice paying gig.
Uh,
in Chicago.
It was horrible.
As,
as wide ballroom.
Most people talk at some people
listening and usually I would call out.
It was like,
this shit sucks.
This is horrible.
This is a horrible performance
situation.
But something in my head that said,
you know what,
just due to time,
go a few minutes short
and just don't acknowledge it and just
power through due to time.
Goodnight everybody,
get the money and go and if you don't
sometimes you don't acknowledge that
you're behind me.
People think it went
well.
They might just be nice to,
you know,
they might've just been night,
who knows,
whatever.
I hated the meet and greet afterwards at
the meet and greet with like some of the
people with the organization or whatever
can take a bunch of pitches and it's
like FDA did after.
Yeah,
it wasn't necessarily eat but it wasn't
an ideal gig.
It was just a,
it was a cash grab,
a cash grab.
But uh,
yeah,
it was like the meet and greet
afterwards.
I hate doing the meet and greet after a
social show because I'm like,
I'd rather be amongst myself and my
friends.
I don't know any of you and you were in
the crowd that I hate it
as a group.
I wanted to talk to you but I'm glad you
brought that up because I remember you
and I were at the same casino that to
your lip casino up in a.
it's like an hour north of Seattle.
Yeah.
I know that gigs suck for you because
that Gig suck for me and it sucks so bad
for Patton Oswald,
that he did a fucking bit about it.
It's on his last CD.
It's on his last fucking you live.
I have never performed for a place where
people were more drunk and rowdy and
crazy.
It is the most.
I mean I had a good time.
It was fun,
but I did an hour.
I might have done 10 minutes of material
and I might be exaggerating,
you know,
it wasn't that bad.
Like they did see a bunch of people.
I'm trying to remember if this was a
right,
but I don't remember being horrible lot.
They just see a lot of people up front
that obviously weren't fans of mine that
just they got casino comps or whatever.
They lose a lot of money.
There is.
And so they got.
So it was weird having these,
you know,
middle age 50,
something like the first couple of rows
full of these Asian ladies that
obviously nothing against Asian ladies,
but I don't think they were familiar
with my work
and they will in the front row.
And so that was.
So I commented on that,
but it wasn't that,
that bad of a Gig.
Yeah,
it was.
But yeah,
it wasn't,
it was way better than the Gig I was
talking about.
That's a,
that's another interesting thing about
that Gig is that Gig was where this was
way before all the cosby stuff came out.
The woman who was the manager came up to
us and we're talking in this and then I
always ask people,
I said,
what's the,
what's the weird shit you've had to deal
with?
Like what's the most annoying comedian
you had to deal with?
Like what's the worst thing you had to
deal with?
And uh,
she goes,
Bill Cosby was the weirdest.
I go,
why?
She goes,
first of all,
he made us a sit down.
He made the staff poffle Jamie with the
beer ready.
You.
Very powerful.
I was about to ask foot another one.
Um,
can I get one of those two?
I'm sorry.
I feel bad with him drinking by himself
though.
He made the audio.
Not The audience.
The staff sit and watch him eat curry.
They just sit and watch him eat.
He wanted everybody that was working
there to sit down and watch him eat
what?
Yeah,
yeah.
Apparently this is his thing or was this
thing.
Thank you.
So he would,
uh,
he would make cheers,
brother.
Cheers.
Good.
Heavier man.
Yeah.
New Way by Cerveza.
He would make the who made the staff
like the people that ticket people.
People,
the ushers.
Security.
They sat down.
They came into his dressing room and
they,
they watched him eat curry.
He sat down and ate and they just
watched him.
That was his.
He wants people to be around him while
he's eating.
Maybe talks to you.
Maybe it doesn't,
but he wants you to be there while he's
eating his curry.
Then I've been doing that for five
years.
Then at the end of the night,
he wanted the security guard to tuck him
in like he lays in bed.
He wants a security guard to tuck him
in.
Put the blanket over him.
Tuck,
tuck.
Shut the lights out and leave.
No please.
No,
no.
Yes,
yes,
please.
No,
man.
There's some weird shit going on.
There was some weird shit going on with
that dude.
Just now.
You just put me on another headline and
Shit just because just probably be in
here.
Joe Rogen had a boat.
Weird bill cosby story.
I've heard the curry thing from someone
else too.
I've heard it from someone else.
Like it was someone else had a similar
story that he had.
Did that,
that he makes a people that work in
these,
uh,
these places.
Sit and watch me eat
some weird shit.
Man.
People in a weird chest that the
weirdest thing.
It's not,
it's not awful.
It's just weird.
Yeah.
Wasn't doing weird shit on the road.
You're very straightforward.
I'm pretty straightforward.
I'd take pictures with everybody after
the show.
Yeah.
That's the weird thing.
Go out and I'll just,
I'll do it for hours.
Yeah.
How do you,
do you pal?
I do enjoy it.
Are you piloting through after like the
10th one or do you just appreciate what
it means to people?
I appreciate it and I.
What I do is I reset,
so like every person I don't go man,
another one,
another one.
Like if you think that way it'll fuck
you up,
but what I do is I,
I just reset.
This is me meeting this person for the
first time and now
me is me meeting this person for the
first time and it's not the hardest
thing to do for an hour or two.
No big deal.
That's my weird thing.
A weird.
It's appreciation.
Things appreciate a pay money.
Yeah.
Excited to see blend.
It's 3,700 people may usually.
It's not all of them that do the picture
thing,
but it might be a thousand.
Yeah.
The one in Chicago was nuts lined
up around the top all the way down the
stairs.
That took fucking forever with that
builds because people post that Joe
Rogan,
Joe Rogan is.
Some people may not even know.
They were like,
oh,
that seems cool.
Let me check out Joe Rogan is and then
they listened to the podcast so I'll
come to a sharp.
The weird part is when some people,
even though there's a giant line,
they got to talk to you.
They got to tell you some fucking story
that takes forever.
You know there's a.
there's a giant line behind you.
I can't.
I need some advice on this is the wrong
place.
Wrong place for advice.
How to like when people ask me to do
some goofy shit and the pitcher like,
can you just do.
Let's make a weird.
Let's make weird faces.
Can I jump on your back?
Let's just.
Let's just look at this camera.
This is.
Get this shit.
Can I tell this?
I'm like,
Nah man,
I'm that dude.
I'm happy to take the picture.
Which he was stopped.
I'm traveling around the country with
this garden gnome.
Want you to hold it up?
Hold it up.
Come on Bro.
I got everybody.
Come on,
man,
I got more or less weak.
He held up the garden.
Yeah.
Well it only takes one person to weird
you out for the rest of the night in his
garden.
Oh Man.
I get thrown off easily by people not
thrown off,
but I can just get put in a weird spot.
Did you get put in a lot of weird spike
like after the whole cosby thing
happened?
Did you get heckled about it at all?
No,
not really.
No.
I think one time I was talking about the
reaction to it and then some guy was
like,
that's all you talk about.
And I was like,
I did like 40 minutes before I even
brought this up.
But besides that,
not really because the people that want
to heckle me about it aren't the people
paid 30,
$35 to see me do a dank.
Yeah.
But you never know.
Some people just get drunk and they just
can't fucking handle themselves.
They just don't know what to do.
It is an interesting thing where people
sometimes think,
I would.
I did ice house and I popped into.
It was a show in a small room,
uh,
last Saturday and uh,
I did a set and it was just the most
talkative crowd.
I started out as a,
uh,
so,
I don't know if you've ever been in
Japan and there's like six people,
like.
No,
no,
we haven't.
No,
no,
no.
I wasn't asking you.
This is not a dialogue.
No,
we haven't been to Japan really.
I ended up yelling at them and roasting
people for about eight minutes.
Did two jokes and then got up out of
there.
You were in the small room in a small
room.
Small Room.
So intimate.
It's only like 80 people.
Yeah,
it was.
And it was packed and it was just
talkative.
Yeah,
that was probably a bad show.
It was.
It was,
yeah.
It was just,
I think they just wanted it to be
roasted and yelled at and they were all
they probably day drunk.
Yeah.
That'll happen.
What are you doing tonight?
You got to.
Scott will do meltdown tonight.
Oh yeah.
What time is that?
Eight 30.
What time you done?
Probably a nine.
Thirty or 10 at the latest.
If you want to come down to the ice
house,
sold out,
show me Bill Burr crystally,
uh,
and Tony inch cliff,
just saying the big room.
There'll be a huge crowd show up to the
big room is the shit at the ice house.
That's the greatest room in the country.
They did perfect.
Perfect Room.
Can't be wrong.
And it's the oldest,
oldest comedy club in the world.
Really?
Yup.
Since when it's from 1960,
1960 as the oldest comedy club.
Comedy Club on Earth.
The Richard Pryor performative.
I'm sure he did.
We lived in La.
I do have.
Everybody did.
George Carlin did because so many
fucking pictures on the wall.
Steve Martin perform there.
Yeah.
I mean,
fill in the blank.
Steven Wright performed.
That means there's so many fucking
pictures on the wall.
People that were there.
It's one of the most classic comedy
clubs on Earth.
Maybe the most classic next to the store
has like a greater history because it
was more greatness.
Like if you go to the store on any given
night,
like the other night it was a Chris rock
and Dave Chapelle.
Dave Chappelle went up and then Chris
rock went up just totally out of
nowhere.
I mean,
that doesn't happen anywhere else where
the seller sometimes.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
Those,
those two clubs,
like we're,
they'll,
someone will pop in,
you know,
like bill barrel pop in Louisville,
pop in,
someone will pop in and if you're there
for a show on a random Tuesday night,
you might get to see one of the best
comics ever.
Just randomly.
I was there a lot.
Did a show with Chappelle and in rock
last Thursday,
this past Thursday.
Right.
Pop there.
Was He doing?
He was doing this stuff about the Oscars
and everything was.
I was gone by then.
I went up earlier.
I brought up Joey Diaz.
Joey Diaz brought up,
Chappelle,
Chappelle brought up.
No,
jody has brought up someone else.
And then that person brought up
Chappelle.
And when Joey got off stage I went home.
Uh,
so I missed it.
But Dave was there the other night.
Man,
fucking hilarious.
He showed up out of nowhere.
I brought him up and he smoked like six
packs of cigarettes on stage.
He can guests,
you're allowed to smoke as performance
stage performance loophole.
Yeah.
It's like a part of your performance.
Yeah,
like a theatrical production.
Like if you've got a cigar on stage and
you're playing some cigar smoking guy,
but fuck man.
He's fun to watch.
Yeah.
There was a show.
Was it two years ago or three?
Two years ago.
It was a.
I went on,
then Kevin Hart went on and then
Chappelle went on and brought rock on
stage,
uh,
want to say Marlon Wayans Bill Bellamy
questlove and where the fuck was.
This is at the comedy cellar and they
were all on stage and once just passing
the mic,
cracking jokes.
That's hilarious.
About an hour and a half.
It was one of the craziest day there was
onstage at the same towel on the little
comedy cellar stage at the same time,
just telling old stories and it was
amazing.
The seller,
what does that seat on it and some
change it.
10 tops.
Those little clubs,
man.
There's something magic about those
little clubs.
It's funny because everybody does stand
up specials in a big place,
but your best performances like that,
like for me at least like the shows that
I have the most fun or like a little
place.
Well yeah,
just because you can.
It's the clubs so more fun.
The people are right there.
Yeah.
The energy is different.
You can kind of,
you could take more liberties as far as
working out a bit.
You know,
you can't really,
you can try stuff in the theater.
You can't leave work out in a theater,
but in a club you can have some misses
and could lose the crowd,
gain them back,
that type of thing.
So the clubs are more fun but you have
the theater is just a look better.
They look it,
but there's some theaters that it works
out like something like the Tabernacle
and Atlanta that places I've shopped
there before.
Yeah,
I shot there my 2012 special and I was
just,
there was just say a couple of weeks
ago.
Yeah.
That place is hot.
That is a hot theater.
It's a theater,
but the acoustics in it are amazing.
And the way it's tiered,
the people even like the people in the
back row,
they're pretty fucking close even though
it's a big place.
Yeah,
that's a great spot.
It's a bunch of these old theaters in
this country that when you performed
there,
you're like a part of a museum or some
shit.
You know,
like you're,
you're performing in a place that's 100
years old and they charge you for it to.
Do they charge you for the history?
Yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
Because you see a.
I didn't see it,
but did you see,
I know you saw Rosie on snl.
No,
I didn't say.
You know what?
I didn't see it.
You didn't watch it.
I didn't watch it.
Joe Rogan didn't watch Ronda Rousey.
I didn't want.
You didn't watch one of the top UFC
stars.
I'm one of the top.
Those are your worlds there.
I'll watch it eventually.
Comedy and fighting.
I'm not into watching things while they
happen.
Really?
Like to wait.
Yeah.
Tell,
tell me it's good and I'll watch.
It was a good.
I haven't seen
it.
I wanted to hear.
I said I started out by saying I haven't
seen it,
but I just assume you had and you would
go off about it for a few minutes some
time time,
but I just wanted to hear your thoughts
on it.
No,
I haven't seen it.
I'm sure it was good.
I heard it was good.
Yeah.
Did you hear it was good.
Jamie didn't see him.
I don't know.
She's a.
she's a fighter.
Yeah.
Do you want to see like a,
a cook racer bike?
No.
No fight or fight.
I would like to see a cook.
You know what I mean?
I mean if someone that I really liked
was doing it,
but I don't watch snl.
I know I'm not a fan.
I don't think it's good.
It's too bad too often for me to get
into it.
Like the amount of good stuff that you
get off the snl versus the amount of
like,
Ooh,
it's way more than it is good.
There's just over the years,
if you accumulate all the different
sketches want me?
God Damn.
I mean,
it's a classic show,
but on any given night,
boy,
you're going to watch a lot of mediocre
shit.
Tina Fey,
we pulled that up so that was really
good.
I wasn't.
I was there for that.
It was a.
It has been great.
Really great sketches in.
I also have a problem with it because I
did news radio with Phil Hartman.
Phil Hartman had incredibly negative
shit to say about SNL,
about the environment,
about what it was like working there
about all the backstabbing behind the
scenes shit.
He hated it.
He fucking hated it.
And when he came over from the yes
secretly,
like,
I don't think he was public about it,
but till now.
Well I think he's probably taught well.
He's asleep.
Post harmoniously homeless.
Is it polls harmlessly posthumous,
posthumous key and peele.
He
post harmlessly posture posture.
Ms Dot Lee
posthumous.
So being alive is hot.
Ms Dot know what is.
I don't know.
It's just,
that's it.
You know,
but that.
Am I saying it wrong now that he's dead
now that he's dead leaked out.
Well,
you know,
what happened was he came over when he
did a news radio that was the first
sitcom that he'd ever done and when he
came over,
like he had this sort of like
standoffish sort of an attitude,
like everybody's competing against
everybody else.
It was like every man for himself,
but then when he realized it wasn't like
that,
he relaxed and then when he relaxed he
and I became friends and he would talk
and you tell me about it and tell me
about like,
what it was like over there.
He was a funny dude,
man.
He used to like to get high.
Whoo.
Yeah.
He would,
he would get barbecued,
get high,
start rapping.
He would get high and go sailing.
That's you'd like to do.
He'd be like,
what would you do this weekend?
Oh,
I got high and I got on my boat.
I went to Esalen.
Yeah,
he liked to go New York out here.
Out here.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was a,
he was an interesting dude.
I
never met anybody who was more
professional,
like he would have these notebooks,
like when you get a script I will
fucking lose my scripts.
I believe I can't find my script,
but isn't any other scripts.
I get another script read off that
script,
but his script was in a binder and he
had like,
like a different colored tabs for
different scenes,
like a yellow tab for the first scene of
blue tab for the second team.
All of his lines were highlighted and he
had notes like you like little
annotations.
You little put little fucking notes on
the side of each thing.
Like hit it like this or do that
emphasis on that.
He was extremely professional.
Well,
yeah.
Yeah.
Like I learned a lot about discipline
and just being a professional,
watching him work.
Like that guy was not successful by
accident.
He was,
he was a hard work and smart dude
and married A.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll be right back.
While you're allowed to call someone to
come when they kill your friend.
No,
definitely.
definitely those times when those times
to ride,
we uh,
I was uh,
in Vegas and uh,
this is a weird thing to happen.
I,
uh,
met up with a friend of a friend.
This girl and her friend,
we hang out for a little bit,
go to the craps table.
I couldn't explain craps to her.
She could not take in the rules of
craft.
She was a little drunk,
but still the,
not the whole craps table,
but the basic,
the seven slash 11 on the first rule is
good.
Two,
three,
12 is bad.
If you get anything else,
that's your point.
You want to hit that point before you
had seven new?
Probably couldn't explain it to me.
I don't understand.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
you get a point.
If you have five,
four or five,
six,
eight,
nine or 10,
that's your point.
And you want to hit that before you hit
seven.
Okay.
But I said this to her eight times and
I,
and she was watching the table also,
so she was just like,
is that good?
Is that
good?
If the guy is handing me money,
it's good.
If he's taken away,
my money is bad.
How about that?
Anyway,
so uh,
so we go,
we get in the back in my hotel
and uh,
her friend was there too.
Long story short,
her friend and I believe in,
we,
we fuck real quick
and then I go hop in the shower.
I'm about to head downstairs to the
awards,
to the porn awards and then she,
she was trying to make me fuck her
again.
She was like,
let's do it.
Let's do it again.
I didn't come and I was like,
we were done.
She was trying to.
She was like,
just,
I'll write you was like,
no,
we already finished.
I guess I didn't get what I was like,
is that a.
and I was like,
am I being a Douche bag?
He was like,
no,
she was being demanded also.
That doesn't feel.
It doesn't feel good.
It didn't really like I'm wondering
like,
okay,
let's go again.
Like also I'm almost 33.
It takes a long time to build back up to
that.
Like the second round is too much for me
right now.
Well,
it depends entirely on how attractive
she is or how attracted you are to her.
That as a human being and physically
like what she looks like and like it
sounds like she was annoying a little
bit.
Yeah.
Going to the porn awards was definitely
more appealing.
And then have sex with her for a second
time.
She was just really.
Is it harder for drunk girls to come
because it's hard for drunk dudes to
come.
Right.
So is it hard for drunk girls to come?
Uh,
so know
there all night and just pounding away.
I don't know.
Are we done yet?
Not yet.
She was.
She was a mess.
That happens.
Does that make some bad decisions?
Sometimes.
Hey,
we all do.
It's part of life.
Especially with alcohol.
It's amazing how many good decisions get
made when you think about all the booze
is flowing around.
Yeah.
Especially in Vegas.
It's amazing.
Like when you go to Vegas,
it's amazing that it's not just chaos
and fucking street fights and bottles
breaking over people's heads.
If you just look at that,
look at a casino is a fucking 100,000
people in there or whatever the hell it
is.
Everyone's boozed up.
It's amazing.
Not losing money.
People fucking up their lives.
Definitely people fucking up their
lives.
My friend Andrew,
he had this dude that used to work with.
He used to work at a restaurant.
This dude saved up his money for 10
years,
10 fucking years.
He had a savings account when he put
together like 20 grand in a savings
account over 10 years is chipping away.
It wasn't making much money.
He's working in a restaurant,
goes to vegas.
He blew it all in one weekend,
pop up,
all gone.
I'll go.
Came back.
Just devastated.
Ten years of working overtime.
Put money away.
Hundred here,
200 there.
Thinking about all those hours that he
spent washing dishes and cleaning up and
all that shit.
Just to blow it on
a weekend.
A weekend.
Still hasn't recovered.
Gone probably killed him.
So he said they're real casual.
Like people do it.
People do do it.
Definitely do.
Do it.
Shouldn't do it over money though,
right?
Unless you owe somebody else money.
We've been paying.
I think Robert Deniro owe somebody
money.
That's why it's doing this shitty
movies.
The intern.
Come
on,
dude.
That was a work of art.
How did that shit because of integrity.
I heard the intern actually.
Did you see it enter?
Yes,
I watched part of it.
Did you like it?
Nope,
I didn't see it.
I heard that.
I heard some people at the intern.
Good,
decent reviews maybe,
but so did like.
There's a lot of shitty movies.
I get good reviews,
but I feel like as far as the law,
like compared to this dirty grandpa one
is like,
have you seen the trailers for this
song?
Like a brief second of it where I sobbed
in neural mechanisms,
Omega narrow face and it said dirty
grandpa.
That's all I saw was like bad owes
people money.
Like with this maybe does move each like
doing a movie like that at one of the
best actors of all time of all time.
Or maybe he doesn't give a fuck.
No,
I think he owes somebody millions.
Well,
there's a lot of people that they get
that lifestyle going and they want to
feed that lifestyle.
They just have to chat.
They want private jets,
they want that house in Spain or
wherever the fuck they like to vacation.
They want a boat,
they wanted this,
they wanted that.
They want to fat apartment in New York
City.
They want a home in Beverly Hills.
They want to pop up.
When you do that,
you need to generate a lot of income and
when guys get older,
especially the money drops
substantially.
That was a big thing that I'm Robin
Williams is experiencing.
He was talking about that before he
died,
that the money just wasn't there
anymore.
There was no.
There's no big money gigs.
Like he would get interesting roles and
these independent films,
but they paid nothing.
Yeah,
and that's why I did that CBS show.
Remember he did that CBS show,
the crazy ones just needed to generate
some money and he had some craziest
state.
He's got some amazing place in northern
California,
like $24,
million bucks actually like hundreds of
acres.
Just giant mansion on it.
Just like the total great gatsby house,
you know,
keep my costs low,
keep your cost low,
cost low,
that's a good move to what?
Until 30 years from now,
30 years from now and then you will off.
When I'm.
When I become the host of family feud,
then it was nice spending that shit
about the price is right.
Family feud is.
I feel like family feud has more room
for humor then prices,
right.
Price is right.
You can get some jokes.
That's true.
But family,
few you can crack.
You got a bunch of different people.
You get jokes off and you know what I
mean?
It's true.
Yeah.
Steve Harvey gets a lot of good laughs
off a lot of jokes.
You got people setting you up.
Softball player.
Yeah.
And it's set up in the questions to,
you know,
a lot of the questions are like they're
just innuendo question.
Oh just fuck.
And you know,
clean jokes.
If they came to you tomorrow with a
family feud,
they go,
look Wayne Brady,
he just doesn't want to do it anymore if
will.
When doing it.
Now he's doing something.
He's doing prices right,
right.
No,
Wayne Brady.
Gary's doing prices right now.
Some show me let's make a deal.
He does.
Let's make a deal.
Oh,
it's weird.
They did rehash these old shows.
Shows a bit around the thirties.
Cheap to make tape,
whatever.
How many.
They taper the day in a day.
They just keep taping them.
Man.
They came to me today with an offer for
now.
I don't know if I could go into it.
It would have to be a nice offer for me
to go on and game show world now.
Yeah,
I,
I did it.
I don't think I could do it again.
I mean,
I definitely could do it again if I was
broke,
but I didn't.
I wouldn't want to do it again unless it
was something unbelievable.
They pitched fear factor to you or you
fear factor?
It existed.
It was a show in Holland.
It was called now or never land.
Oh.
And then they came to me because I had a
development deal with NBC to do a Sitcom
and it came to me and they said,
hey,
there's this thing,
you know,
we want you to come in and have a
meeting with it.
And I started with making fun of it when
I went in there daily.
They didn't want me at first because I
wasn't making fun of it because I was.
Because they were a second dogs on
people and making them eat animal dicks
and shit.
I was,
I was mocking it.
And then the purdue,
one of the producers was like,
listen,
this guy's not going to work.
He's like,
he's not taking it seriously.
We need these people to be scared.
And then the other producer,
my friend David Horwitz,
was like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Look at what we're doing this.
We need someone to mock this.
This is fucking ridiculous.
It shows ridiculous.
Like if it's going to be successful,
we probably need a comedian and you
probably need someone to mock it.
And I wound up doing it,
but I never thought I thought it was
going to be canceled in June.
When did,
how many seasons was 600,
48 episodes.
Which,
uh,
episodes should we look for if we want
to see you dead in the eyes while I
wasn't dead in the eyes.
I did way better than that.
It was right around episode three or
four.
I started getting high as fuck.
I would get so high that I,
I could feel the earth spinning it.
I would,
I would take pot lollipops with me to
the set and I would just suck on pot
lollipops and that because that's a slow
release and the pot lollipops will kick
in like an hour into the show.
But I'm functional,
like I know how to do it.
I can operate hot.
Were you married to a fear factor now?
Did you ever hook up with a contest?
No.
No,
no.
That's not a smart move.
Yeah.
Doesn't seem smart.
But we just,
we both agree that we do dumb things
sometimes.
The dumbest Shit that you've ever done
because of your Dick
was a bad question.
No,
no,
the dumbest shit.
You just look down at your Dick and you
go,
how dare you put the fuck did you do to
me man fucking position.
It's definitely.
I mean girl in Vegas,
that wasn't a good decision when I was
just like,
it doesn't seem like the worst decision.
Worst case,
worst thing happened as she wanted to
come and she didn't come
and but she is now.
I just,
I don't like when I end up where I'm
like,
oh,
this chick is just hit for the story
I was in when I was in San Jose.
I was a for.
I brought this girl but I brought her a
couple of friends but I have friend.
The dude leaves,
her friend crashes on the couch.
It's a sweet girl called it to the room
with me and it happens and then I wake
up,
I look over,
she kinda fucking with her phone or
something and I'm like,
I am an instinct.
Let me see your phone.
And then I scroll through the pictures
and she had taken like selfies with me
sleeping in the background
and then I scrolled through some more.
She had posted a snapchat the night
before,
like hanging out in Hannibal.
Buress is room.
I cut my face,
wasn't in the sleep and pitched it.
But that would have been the implication
if you were following her.
See I don't,
I don't have a snapchat.
Yeah.
So I don't.
It was just pitches with
on the camera law on like these cameras.
I wasn't on her,
but that's like you,
if you do a snapchat,
I guess you could save the image that
you put on snapchat.
You can save it to your right to your
phone.
And so I deleted all that shit and I was
just like,
get outta here.
What did she say?
She knew she,
she knew she was at it,
like fuck else.
She doesn't say she was like,
she was young and Goofy,
but it was just,
Oh my God,
what am I doing?
He's fucking goof nuggets.
But I also,
but also don't want to data famous
chicken.
Then had everybody in my business.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It doesn't seem like a good moat.
You know the problem with that too,
it's like a famous person is not more
attractive to a guy.
Like if you meet a hot girl and she's
just interesting and cool and she's not
famous or you meet a hot grows,
interesting and cool and his famous.
They don't.
There's no one.
One's not better than the other.
Matter of fact,
the famous one carries a lot of baggage.
Whereas for a girl,
I think she meets a guy like you,
like,
oh,
he's funny and he's smart and he's
famous.
He's famous.
Like the fame means something to them it
doesn't.
Fame doesn't necessarily mean things to
mostly.
Let me some.
The,
some guys just the EU.
If you watch tv or you see a girl in a,
in a magazine or you see in the video,
you will.
If you just saw a bunch of dope ass
instagram pages,
you like,
Yo,
that is that attainable to them
because you know,
I heard,
I heard stories about old school movie
stars or whatever.
Like in the eighties,
they just flipped through a magazine
like her go get her for me and that's
how they would pull,
like that was their tender
flipping through a magazine,
like who was that or shit like that.
So I think definitely think those,
those models and it's something to that
for,
for some guys.
It's an excitement to that.
Yeah.
But.
And they saw that girl at a club for it
be just as excited about her.
Yeah.
Without knowing about.
But maybe you know,
I mean I've seen,
you know,
some that I'm like,
man,
I liked that.
I liked that song.
Right.
And someone's talented.
But then I do feel it feels iffy.
So it feels just weird sometimes.
Oh well there's that whole world of,
you know,
when you get in that red carpet world
within that world of they follow your
relationship because you put your
relationship out there and all your
photos.
I never did.
Even when,
even in 2008 to two where I had a
girlfriend,
like I didn't even put in a relationship
on facebook and it wasn't to like mess
around with other guys.
It was just because I didn't feel like
strangers because I had some facebook.
I didn't feel like strangers should know
who my girlfriend is unless you see me
out and about,
but you shouldn't just be able to go on
my facebook page and like,
oh,
he's dating her.
I'm here for the majority of people.
It'd be no problem at all,
but it's just a few creepers that it
wouldn't be a problem happen.
This thought the whole world is very
strange when it comes to that shit.
It's very social media's a totally new
landscape that our parents didn't have
to deal with.
Their parents had never.
Nobody had to deal with it until this
generation is the first generation ever
that's put their whole life out there.
I said,
I have friends who put their fucking
kids.
They put their kids pictures all over
the internet and everything like that.
I'm like,
okay,
maybe.
I guess.
I guess you could do that,
but it seems like.
Did you ask the kids?
You know what I mean?
Like
are you gonna know what your kids look
like?
Yeah.
That is weird and I mean with some
people that's how you get,
you know,
I mean I guess you would add,
you could make it private but that's how
you share it with family members that
you just put it on facebook and you
said,
but there's also some people like to put
that image out there.
That was one of the things that Phil
Hartman and I talked about when he was
trying to break up with his wife.
He was like,
I think that if I got divorced I
wouldn't get the same movies.
And I said,
why?
He goes because my,
my image is the family man.
Like I,
I need
like that.
Those are the movies I get.
I need my wife and my kids and all that
stuff.
That's like a part of like what I'm
selling.
And I was like,
wow,
I never even thought of that,
you know,
because I was young and single and I was
like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I guess.
But some people look at it that way.
They want to sell a package.
Like,
hey look at me.
I'm a good guy.
Hey,
here I am.
At my kid's birthday party,
look,
I'm holding a baby.
You know,
comedians would known to be degenerates.
we're known to be dirty people,
so much so that when somebody is that
they like,
Holy Shit,
we liked this guy.
Gaffigan come before the poem.
I was just going to say gap.
Regan,
where are you fry?
Every
comp before him.
Before the pope?
Yeah.
Gaffigan perform in front of the pump.
It was the most fucked up about that.
He was on the Colbert show.
Okay.
Colby,
if you don't know it was a Catholic,
like a serious Catholic and he's on the
Colbert show with Maria Shriver and
they're talking about how great it is to
be a Catholic and they're,
they're on there and I'm like,
am I?
Is this real life like you guys are
talking about a cult.
You're in an ancient cult kid fuckers
and you're going to go see the,
the head kid fucker.
He's the king of the kid fuckers and you
guys are pretending that this is all
fun.
This is all great stuff being a
Catholics.
Wonderful.
It's amazing.
It's just like such a great tradition
and history to it.
Like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I was raised Catholic.
I went to Catholic school when I was a
little kid.
Fuck all that.
That is key to put my kids through that
as an adult to be an adult and to
somehow another promote that it's
madness.
That is madness is.
I mean,
yeah.
I don't.
I'm not a religious person at all.
I don't,
I don't need it.
I think,
you know,
it's cool when they give people food and
shit.
Churches when they donate.
I think churches are great.
Yeah.
I think church is a great.
And communities,
I think it's a good thing where people
get together and just be nice to each
other on Sundays.
Yeah.
Regardless of songs.
Yeah,
there's a lot of good to that,
but Catholicism as a religion,
like growing up in it and seeing all the
damage that it does and the guilt,
all the fucking guilt and weirdness that
it came to us.
Oh Man.
Catholic school was horrible.
Yeah.
Horrible Shit Man.
You to go to Catholic high school?
No,
no,
no.
It's great.
No,
when I was early,
I only went to first grade.
We stuck with you that much.
They would just this,
this woman,
her name is sister Mary Josephine.
Just fucking,
she was a monster.
She was just the meanest lady.
First of all,
I didn't go to kindergarten,
so that was my first time in school at
all.
So like first grade was the first time
in school and um,
you know,
as she was mean Jo,
because she wasn't getting no Dick,
man,
Catholic ladies don't be fucking it all.
So they angry does death definitely that
nuns don't be fucking,
they need the fuck and then they'll
loosen up a little bit.
You know what,
stop and the dude's,
what are they doing?
That's why they fuck kids.
They're all bent up and fucking
tightened up.
We had a kid that,
uh,
in my high school that became a priest,
he was gay as fuck.
Everybody knew he was gay.
We knew he was gay and he's going to
become a priest.
And I remember thinking,
this is so bizarre.
I guess this guy is avoiding pussy by
becoming a priest because we're like,
hey billy,
you when are you going to have a
girlfriend hold?
The Lord's got me wrapped up and he
became a Catholic priest.
I mean,
I don't know if he ever went.
I mean I didn't talk to them after high
school,
but I'm assuming he went with it,
but he was.
That was the whole thing and he was
going to be a.
He was going to be a father.
Billy was going to be a father,
father billy.
Oh,
there he goes.
The fact that they think that there
needs to be new people to teach religion
at all.
We need new people like now why don't
you just.
Do you need somebody else to say this
shit has been being said.
It's nothing new to be added to it.
What's an organization?
Yeah.
This is an organization that needs,
needs members to grow.
It's a spooky organization that the
amount of.
Like.
One of the things that happened when
ratzinger was the pope,
the glass guy who stepped down.
One of the reasons why stepped down,
it was revealed that that guy had
relocated child molesters and one of
them that have relocated walnut
molesting a hundred deaf kids,
a hundred deaf kid likes this guy was
they relocated them,
some new place in rats.
They knew he was a pedophile.
I mean,
this isn't,
it's not a new thing.
I mean,
pedophilia in the Catholic church is
fucking bananas.
It's so rampant.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you had that many pedophiles say like
in Nascar,
how long would it take for the shutdown
NASCAR?
Nascar is a fucking crazy pedophile
ring,
but because it's the Lord the Lord's
attached all this kid fucking at somehow
or another,
that guy's not in jail.
They just moved that guy to some new
place and you know,
now you don't see him anymore.
But he,
he can't.
He was one of those guys.
They were trying to cry.
They were trying to try him for crimes
against humanity.
There was all these,
um,
these people that were,
that were petitioning while he was the
pope to get him tried.
And uh,
then he had a step down.
This new guy stepped in,
this new guy.
He's pretty cool.
It's like as far as pope's go,
gotta like he got rid of the throne.
Got Pretty decent.
Normal Chair.
Yeah.
That should change everything.
He doesn't ride around the Pope Mobile.
Whether you ride around in a Fiat,
if they shoot me,
they shoot me.
Yeah.
As people.
When was the last time they went after
the pope?
Right?
Right before they built the Pomo bill
shot the pope.
I mean people shot the pope before.
Look,
you know it was going to shoot the pope.
Someone who got fucked by a priest.
Yeah,
probably.
And you're talking about thousands of
people.
It is a banana's religion.
If you really stop and think about
how many people have been molested by a
priest.
When I was a kid,
I would hear about it when I was in
Catholic school.
I would hear about it in hush tones
amongst relatives and people that the
father did something to him and there
there was this and stay away from father
o'malley and stay away from this guy
likes.
Yeah.
I had a friend of mine who who had the,
he had to stay over during high school
for like a track and field thing and
they,
they made them stay at the church
because he was in Catholic school and
he's like,
I'm literally fighting this old guy off
of me.
He goes,
I'm 16 years old.
His case,
reaching his hand in my pants,
he's grabbing my Dick.
He's like,
he was drunk with wine.
I'm fighting.
This old child molester off was this
guy.
He was like the old guy.
He's old,
but my friend was like 15 high school,
14,
15.
Had to beat the shit out of it.
Olga,
really behaving.
Maybe the old guy's got skills
doing it for years.
He knows how to molest kids.
Scott moves.
He used.
I mean they must have moves,
right?
Like you have moved with girls.
Everybody has moves.
When you have your move is,
hey,
I'm Hannibal.
What's that?
I don't say that,
but I was like,
Hey,
what's up?
Blah blah,
blah.
You want to drink?
All right,
second location,
blah,
blah.
Let's go back.
Take him to a second location.
Yeah,
you get them in a different environment
or this place is great right now.
Let's go.
Yeah,
you got to move around and moving
around.
That makes things more activist.
It's a full night,
a full evening like dinner and a movie,
right?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Dinner.
And you go to a movie like you had a lot
of shit happening,
right?
A show,
but I mean young guys that are trying to
get laid.
I mean that's why people wear nice
clothes and that's why people wear
jewelry.
They drive a nice car.
Why do they do that?
Because they want to show like,
hey,
look at me.
I'm something special.
You've got maybe a few good jokes.
They tell maybe they,
you know,
they're uh,
did just a smooth talker.
It would feel weird to,
to be able to fuck because of my car.
I don't have a car,
I don't own a car.
But if it would feel weird,
I think that would feel more weird than
fucking because of fame.
A car.
Like,
look at this shit,
get it,
let's go.
What?
You have to.
Especially in La,
you have to really come.
Correct.
I mean,
you gotTa,
you gotta come with some strong fucking
automobile if you want to fuck for your
car is.
There's so many nice cars out here.
You gotta have like a Bugatti.
You got to have some shit that's a house
to house on wheels when you can't have a
uber sticker on that shit.
No matter how nice it is to.
They have stickers on Hooper's.
They put stickers on carts,
they have a you.
Well,
if you have a Bugatti and you have an
uber,
you can say it's a goof.
I like to pick people up just to freak
them out.
That's a nice.
Uber's out there.
They got like s five hundreds binges.
Really try and make those payments.
Yeah.
If you haven't asked 500 and you say,
all right,
look,
I like a nice car but I can't afford it.
But if I just work two nights a week for
Uber,
that would be my car payment.
You could do that.
Yeah,
I could see it.
I can see it.
I've heard about like.
Yeah,
I've heard a lot about just uber drivers
push.
No,
no,
all levels of cars.
But definitely going in hard on loan
limit.
Did I know that in A.
I mean there's obviously been a couple
stories of,
you know,
things happening like,
but that definitely just dim like,
Yo what's up and just blah blah blah
blah blah,
and just really go on it.
That's one thing I liked about being in
Japan
is that a taxi drivers don't say Shit to
you.
Uber drivers talked too much.
Uber drivers talk to taxi drivers too.
But Uber drivers or drivers like pro.
I just want to.
I,
uh,
when I was in Chicago,
I was heading for my hotel.
My hotel is downtown.
Had an old hair.
It's about 40 minutes early in the
morning,
a little bit hung over and over.
It's a comic from that sort of knew
maybe 10 years back in Chicago driving
an uber.
And he started pitching me.
Yes.
And I hadn't seen him in years.
I didn't even,
we weren't that close when I,
when I did a,
when I was in Chicago and he was like,
I got these ideas,
man.
Can you link me with Stephen Merchant
and Baba Baba who?
Stephen Merchant.
Stephen merchant is a the tall guy from
the office.
Okay.
That was in the original art and extras
is Ricky Gervais work with Ricky
Gervais'.
Okay.
So He's just like,
oh,
ask him.
Just hadn't seen this dude in 11 years
or some shit.
And I'm like,
hostage on the way to the airport for 40
minutes.
Did he know that it was gonna be you or
was it just totally random?
He didn't know what's going to be me
because I have a fake name.
Uber.
Oh.
So uh,
yeah,
it just,
it was totally random.
It's like Oh,
what's up are recognized me.
But it was just like I'm getting pitched
right now.
It's like six in the morning.
Oh No.
And you're tired of 40 minute ride.
You can't tell him to shut the fuck up.
Getting that was just like,
yeah man,
it sounds like a real cool idea.
See that's why I stopped using car
services to take me to the airport
because I just didn't want to talk to
anybody.
I'd rather just listen to podcasts and
just chill,
drive myself.
And then when I get to,
like when I do clubs or colleges or
whatever,
or a colleges will never do colleges
when I do theaters or whatever.
I just rent a car.
Yeah,
I liked that better
man.
I mean,
most of the time you run into cool
drivers most of the time.
But the problem is if you don't,
it's a pain the ass.
Like if you run into one dude who just
talks too much,
does take it.
Takes your mental energy.
Like it's really.
I mean it's a,
you know,
a bit of an exaggeration to say it like
this,
but it's like food,
like,
you know,
15 minutes,
somebody can kind of steal your soul a
little bit.
Like Tony Hinchcliffe were in the car
once and this fucking dude just joined
in on our conversation.
Like we're talking about some important
shit,
you know.
And Tony's asking me some question,
he's asked me for advice and I'm like,
well I think in the guys like,
what you should do is,
well,
you gotta tell her to mama talking about
a girl.
I'm like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Hold on dude.
You're not even supposed to be here like
you're,
you're just in.
You're like,
you're here,
but you're not supposed to be in this
conversation.
This is a conversation like,
this is my friend.
He's asking me advice.
You don't even know him.
And so like the whole rest of the day
was just bizarre because this dude was
driving us around and just chimed in.
No matter what we talked about,
just looking at the looking at you in
the rear view,
Mike got eyes on the road,
motherfucker.
That,
that,
that thing is to see cars behind us.
It's not to have conversations when
you're looking,
when you're.
When the guy's driving and he's looking
at you in the rear view mirror,
he that motherfucker's holding your
attention hostage because anything can
happen now because he's not necessarily
paying attention to the road and you're
like,
oh Jesus Christ,
what does this guy's playing?
You might as well be texting right now.
He's still at the rear view mirror.
Was that I got in the car no lot.
This dude was a.
He had like a,
either his phone,
a bigger phone or a tablet like in the
middle and he was watching some type of
scientology youtube video here in la
while he was driving and he just kept.
He was driving and kept on like glancing
at it and I and as I said,
hey man.
I said,
hey,
turn it off.
Yeah,
because he was for real,
like looking down.
Oh my God.
The videos.
Like,
what do you use?
sorry about that.
I just say I get that you have a lot of
downtime,
but now isn't that one of those times
stopped looking down at this and he had
also,
he had that shit in the speakers.
That's what made it.
It was like this weird ass youtube and
then scientology is the like,
what the fuck are you?
Who are you meant?
I had this dude that was texting the
entire time.
He picked me up at the airport and he
was taking me somewhere and the entire
time he's on his phone.
He's got his phone in his lap and he's
driving and he's just doing this.
Looking down one,
two,
three.
Look it up,
look it down.
One,
two,
three.
Look it up.
Look it down.
Once it was a fucking perilous terror
field ride because we're on the highway
and this guy and I'm like,
hey man,
you're making me nervous.
Don't worry everything.
No problem.
Got It.
I'll stop right now and then a couple of
seconds later you get another text and
I've just got to this and it was locked
it down.
Look it up.
Looking down,
looking up,
looking down,
looking at when you're looking down your
fucking cars.
Traveling like a hundred feet,
200 feet,
300 feet.
Anything can happen during that time.
You're not looking.
Dude,
could fuck up and come into your lane.
Some knew some shit could be on the road
that you didn't see.
Stinks.
Caraway for rental.
In the few years it's going to be
rental,
self driving cars.
Well they already have that with
Mercedes and the Mercedes has a self
driving car now.
Yeah.
Would you get in the fucking car?
The s classes?
Yeah.
You still get on the highway.
You like press a navigation system.
Fucking get your hands off the steering
wheel and you sit back and that
motherfucker drives itself.
It slows down,
it turns.
But does Avis have that shit yet?
That's what I mean.
I want to be able to go to Columbus,
Ohio.
That's kind of.
I like to upgrade to the self driving,
but when that happens it's going to be
more boring but more safe,
you know,
because you wonder if you'll be able to
like take it out of self driving mode,
but then he'll be,
have like self driving cars and then
asshole slamming into self driving cars.
Oh yeah.
That'll be a problem.
So don't get weird in the next five
years.
We're already weird stuff is going to
get really weird.
You want to see weird.
Go to brody.
Stevens is periscope all day long.
He periscopes,
periscopes,
everything he does.
He periscopes his drive to the comedy
store.
He periscopes at the comedy store.
Got Arrested last night for it,
bro.
You got pulled over and the cops pulled
up behind him and uh,
detained him.
I think
he was in a spot where a robbery was a
reported.
I guess it wasn't him.
He got,
he didn't get arrested for periscope at
the same time he was periscoping.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
They don't know.
Obviously they don't always.
Brody motherfucking fucking.
I step out real quick.
Oh,
you gotTa pee.
How dare you?
Yeah,
that's pretty funny.
Yeah.
He's sitting there talking to the,
to like normal periscope that he does
and uh,
you see the lights come up behind them.
He's like,
oh,
oh.
And he came back up late,
like an hour later with a new periscope
saying like,
what happened?
Yeah.
Every time I run into him at the comedy
store,
he's on periscope.
I've been in like five of his
periscopes.
Yeah,
that's great.
He walks in periscope and yeah,
he's a,
he's a fucking character man.
He's such a character,
but he's one of those guys.
It's embraced that aspect of social
media at a ridiculous level.
Like you literally will.
Periscope has whole life.
Brian was doing it a lot for awhile,
but he's kind of abandoned.
He still does it some,
but yeah,
I don't do it at all anymore.
I haven't periscoped in a year.
It's good.
It's taken off a little bit more because
it's,
it's on apps now for TV.
It's like the Apple TV.
It's built in there.
Something else had it built into it too,
so you can watch it on a big screen
without having to have it just on your
phone and having to choose what you
watch and they're giving you things to
look at.
Now to dude,
I'm super suspicious about apple tv now
because my apple tv
used to work great until the new apple
TV came out.
Now my appletv fucks up all the time.
It kicks me off and reboots it,
stops shows and goes right back to the
main menu.
And then I'm,
I'm suspicious about one another beer.
I'm,
I'm suspicious about the,
um,
there's a class action lawsuit that
someone filed about the old phones.
They said that the old phones stopped
working when the new operating system
would come out because the new operating
system is designed for the new phones
and they had made it so that the old
phones were slow.
I wonder if.
I wonder if they would actually do that
to Brian thing.
So Brian's convinced it could also be a
matter of just like they're making so
much great new software that the old uh,
processes and whatnot just aren't made
to use it.
Yeah.
But that's not,
that's not fun.
It's not fun to think like that.
Not The way they sell it either though.
They sell it as the.
You should be able to use it.
Yeah.
Well you should be able to have an
iphone four and fucking keep the old
operating system and be good.
It used to work.
Good.
Why does it work good anymore?
I don't want to fucking play games on
it.
I don't want to watch videos.
I just want to.
Goddammit,
right is a uh,
you need an actual opener.
They just announced their first time for
the,
I think ever the sales on iphones or
down
for the quarter.
However they wonder why because
everybody has one.
And that's why is because everybody's
switching to Samsung.
Are you?
Are you switching Samsung?
Is that what you're saying?
Those new samsungs are pretty fucking
slick.
They are very slick.
The new ones are about as good.
Thank you sir.
The new ones are about as good as an
iphone.
I'm going to adjust as good with some
features that iphones don't have.
You know,
I'm,
I'm being a ship.
I just did a Samsung.
Samsung is great,
man.
I have a Samsung.
I got one of those galaxies.
Yeah.
The phone that we use for this podcast.
They're good.
You got one right there.
Looking at email,
you're not fucking around,
but do you miss certain apps that are
only iphone native?
No.
No,
I would.
I would like the instagram for,
for androids.
Bullshit.
You think instagram?
Yeah.
It sucks to update.
Oh yeah,
the new one's better.
They fixed it.
I think so.
The old one was dog shit.
Don't get defensive.
I'm not defensive.
I just started.
I'm having a good time.
I really didn't.
I wasn't a definitive it out.
Okay.
We're live on the Internet right now.
That cameras on that camera is live on
the Internet,
right?
Yeah.
What's up everybody?
Thank you.
It's been two years,
man.
I know.
It's Kinda crazy.
Yeah.
We got to do more shit together,
man.
I really enjoy your company.
It's a fun time.
I'm enjoying it.
I got more stories.
Crazy stories.
Got Any more you'd like to share with
people before we wrap this up?
What's a.
A
a crazy one that happened.
So I'm in a.
In Japan.
I went out there for winter vacation
just for fucking around.
Yeah,
a couple of other comics when out there.
Eric Andre,
bion bowers.
I love Byron.
Byron is a crazy.
He's a great dude.
He's a maniac.
Fun Guy.
Yeah,
a and a couple of times.
J Dot Kara Preda.
Nick brought the foot dug pound and a
couple of other people out.
They took a trip out to Japan.
I popped out there,
got out there January third.
I was hanging out with this girl out
there.
We go to this bar,
so nice bar in Japan called Jbs jazz
blues.
So also a lot of the bars out there,
the names of them in English are very on
the nose.
It's a hip hop club.
It's Club Harlem.
Shit like that shit.
Like Oh the club to play.
So let's call it ebony,
like shit.
Like really on the nose.
So we go to jazz blues,
so if you haven't in Tokyo,
check it out.
It's just,
it's a small bar.
Uh,
I don't know the owner's name,
but it's full of vinyl records and you
can just request.
He has all types of vital records is in
a lot of Japanese people.
They were Americans or it was some
Japanese people but it was in Tokyo at
this bar in Tokyo.
In Tokyo is some but not like it.
You don't see a lot but the bar.
But the bar itself,
it only holds 10,
15.
It's a small spot.
Ten or 15 people if that.
Yeah,
pack like 10,
15.
Like it'll be something.
Yeah,
it's this room.
Maybe it's my.
It's smaller than this room.
Whoa.
So it's a nice little
bar.
They also had this area called the
golden guide,
which is,
has a,
it's an area full of small bars that
only hold four or five people that are
smaller than this.
Smaller than that place,
like super small places.
So at this bar,
the guy just knows the collection.
It's,
it's,
it's a wall full of vinyl and then his
son behind it.
Behind the bar also,
so you.
I was just saying he,
he what you want to hear,
say a stew,
stevie wonder songs in the key of life
and he just walks right up to the spot.
I mean it's obviously Stevie,
but he just walks up to the,
a bunch of records he didn't even
flipped through and nothing.
He just knew exactly what he meant.
Foot grabbed it,
put it on there.
So we were hanging out and it was just
A.
I'm with a girl who was half Japanese,
half white,
but she knew Japanese and English and
she saw a friend there so they started
talking in Japanese.
There's this white chick there that's
super drunk,
like blush on her eyes is all fucked up.
Weird.
Like she had that stereotypical like
see,
look,
central casting drunk.
You know what I mean?
Like she was going to an audition to be
a drunk lady right after she was at the
bar.
So they start talking in Japanese.
She talked to me a little bit.
I found out she lives in the same
neighborhood that I do.
Williamsburg,
Brooklyn.
She starts,
they started talking to Japanese.
She's like,
you know what they're saying?
I'm like,
Nah,
she just be in play.
And then she says,
is this your wife?
I said,
no,
that's not my wife,
is that your wife said,
no,
stop my wife and snatch your wife.
I was like,
why'd you just asked me the same thing
three times in a row?
Because I just,
she just asked me.
I guess he was that faded dog.
Her face turns and she's just,
I could just see her getting upset.
She starts flipping out like,
fuck you,
you didn't have to be disrespectful.
No,
fuck him.
He thinks because he's without Japanese
girl.
He's like started,
you know,
you think you have some cool comedian.
So then it real that she knew I didn't,
I didn't tell her who.
I hadn't saved my job or anything to us.
So she knew me.
She showed him,
so now I,
she is in a different,
like,
she's a super upset.
Fuck you,
you came all the way over here,
you're doing.
And then she just started getting ready.
She was like,
he's a monkey,
a monkey.
I'm like,
no,
this is great.
Am I being called a monkey by a white
woman from Williamsburg in Tokyo right
now?
What the fuck is why you should take
pictures of her,
put it up all around Williamsburg.
I just.
Just this dummy have you said I should
have.
I thought about starting to film,
but it was just so weird that she,
for Real,
all I did objectively,
I wasn't that fade,
so I'd have a clear,
a recall of a situation.
I only just said,
why you just asked me if this is my wife
three times.
Like what I told,
you know the first two times sake.
And she just went off tilt.
Man.
It was the weirdest.
It was one of the weirdest things.
What is a weird thing that happens
sometimes when someone's famous like you
and they're not where they feel like
you.
It's possible that you think you're cool
because you're famous.
Like you think you're better than them,
you know,
so like they look for any little thing,
any little thing.
Oh,
you think you're too good?
You know that they're looking for that.
They're too good to listen to me.
Repeat Myself.
I've listened to it,
but I.
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you that you're doing this.
It was the.
It was so weird,
man.
Alcoholism.
When someone's that blasted,
who knows what's going on in their mind.
No,
it definitely was.
I could tell she was because when she
started getting raised,
it didn't affect me,
but it was just.
I could tell she goes,
I accidentally hurt her feelings,
but she was trying to hurt you.
She was trying to hurt me and I could
see she was almost on the verge of when
all I said was I stopped saying the same
thing over and over,
which I would say to anybody if I said
that to one of my buddies,
they were like,
Oh shit,
I'm fucked up.
You know what I mean?
But if you don't know someone,
they say that to them and then
especially if they're dumb and no one
calls them out on their stupidity,
it could be devastating.
Yeah.
That sometimes people do have that sort
of thing.
No.
When they meet you like,
that's that guy from TV.
I've seen him on comedy central.
I just want to call her and talk to them
and it was fine,
but she just was,
she got into repetitive boat.
It was just,
I just couldn't handle you checking her.
Checked her too hard.
It was,
it was a soft check was light work.
But I do find that sometimes where even
like I'll joke around with people too
harsh.
It's like it's like a,
uh,
it's like a fighter pilot,
you know,
sparring with some,
like it's not the same.
Like you can't act the same when you
can,
but if people don't know you then it's
just,
it can be kind of taken aback and throw
it off because it's like,
oh,
this dude's ass.
So it's like,
no,
that's just how I talk with people.
Well also you're a New York comic or
your comment that lives in New York.
Yeah,
in New York in particular.
It's a fun place to be a comic,
fun place to interact with other comics.
But like people are fucking ruthless to
each other.
Yeah.
Like what did I just tell you bitch?
And you would start.
We would laugh,
but if you said that to someone in real
life that's like super sensitive,
like what did I just tell you?
Bitch?
Be like,
you don't have to call me bitch,
man.
What kind of a fucking piece of shit are
you,
man?
You think just because you're on comedy
central,
you can call me boot.
Yeah.
Like even kind of except the seller or
key drivers in a couple of other people.
Hey,
what's up?
Stupid.
It is stupid over here.
Says this and that's how you toggle it.
Yeah.
Just like that is idiot.
Like,
Hey,
stupid.
You do it.
Are you doing?
You got to set tonight stupid.
Let me just sit down and the text and
it's just know it's done when it's done
with love,
you know?
Yeah.
It's done with love and that's something
maybe we understand that other people
don't.
I did a,
uh,
a theater in Miami and Wanda,
Wanda Sykes and Keith Robinson were
doing the early show and I was doing the
late shift fillmore.
Um,
I think it might've been the fillmore.
I don't remember what theater was,
but anyway,
um,
when I got there I said,
I said to them they were leaving and
then I got to my dressing room and there
was two napkins that they'd left.
Wanda left a Napkin.
I hope you have a great show.
Joe,
you know,
kill them.
Wanda.
And then Keith Robinson wrote,
I hope you bomb harder than you ever
have in your life,
your friend.
I'd saved it.
I took a picture of it and put it
online.
He's to me,
it was funny,
but like,
if someone's like fucking real sensitive
and they see something like that,
they'd be like,
well what the fuck,
Keith,
I haven't seen you in 10 years,
man.
Believe me.
But it was warm for me.
I felt good.
They took the time to do that.
You know?
It felt good to me,
but he keeps graded that that's.
But that's not the whole New York style
of comedy.
It's a very different style than like La
Comics.
Like la comics is not
sort of the only.
I know there's only a handful that I
know well that,
you know,
I'm close with like that,
but it's different.
It is different.
Yeah.
Well,
New York's a harsher environment.
I did have a situation where somebody
joked with me,
it was a very specific situation with
somebody joked with me and I haven't
talked to that person for five years
because of that joke to a,
not to say the name of won't say that.
So I,
uh,
when I was in South Carolina,
Charleston,
South Carolina,
a 2011,
2010,
2011 the day before my,
uh,
my,
the day before my birthday,
a few years ago,
I,
uh,
I was out there doing some shows with
Aziz and I was hanging out with,
hanging out at bars,
hanging out with a couple girls,
hop in the car with them to go back to
wherever the fuck dude.
And then
wake up in the stretcher.
We got in a car accident and shit.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
This is where I got this scar from in.
Uh,
so I had my skull fracture that had a
few stitches right here.
Whoa.
It's like the day before my birthday,
it was my birthday on a stretcher.
I woke up like,
I don't remember.
I don't remember,
like,
well I don't remember.
Yeah,
I just woke up in the hospital and uh,
so uh,
uh,
it's something.
And I'm in the hospital.
I had like,
you know,
tweeted out a photo of my fucked up ass
face and
to go back a few years ago,
it was a comic friend of mine.
I had a got tickets to see the clippers
or the Lakers and I invited him.
I pick him up my rental car out here and
I wasn't wearing my seatbelt and he's
like,
I'm not gonna,
wear your seat back.
And flood was like,
no,
I'm not wearing my seat.
I got sometimes I don't wear my
seatbelt,
whatever.
And so I'm laid up after I posted this
ad,
I'm laid up in the hospital but with my
scope.
And then this was like,
I hadn't even been talking to them that
much around this time and had heard and
I get a text that you gonna wear your
seat belt now.
And I was like,
what?
The fuck,
but I thought I didn't think that was
the right time.
My skull was fractured and I had never
been in a month,
but I don't think he meant.
I don't,
I don't think he meant it maliciously,
but I think it was a bit tone deaf.
What do you think?
It depends on who it is.
Like if it was a good friend,
like if I got
in a car accident and like Ari,
Ari Shaffir.
If he did that I would laugh.
Right.
Cause he's a,
he's such a close friend that he can't
really do anything that would hurt me.
You know what I mean?
But I think it was based off of he,
he was holding onto this seatbelt
argument from a couple of years ago.
Oh,
so you guys had a real disagreement?
It might've been real on it,
but it was just me being more like a
seatbelt that day.
He must not have liked that dude because
if you really liked him you'd laugh.
Like if it was Keith Robinson,
when you laugh,
don't.
I mean it's like his style,
like that's something you could say.
You bet you wear a seatbelt now.
Dummy.
Like he would say you would probably
laugh if you saw that man meant.
Depends on how bad your hurt too.
When you're hurt,
you're not feeling any jokes.
You're fucking head's pounding.
You got a fractured skull
in late.
Yeah,
fractious.
Go doped up is my birthday now.
Oh,
I didn't like that job.
I was talking about it with a mutual
friend and I think I might try to bury
the hatchet.
So five years later.
Hey man,
listen.
It takes time.
So stubborn person put A.
Yeah,
well I understand there's certain people
can joke with you,
like someone may be like,
well here you and Keith or someone like
that joke around like that and then
they'll see you at a club and they'll
say some stupid shit to you.
And they'll think it's funny because
they think they can get away with things
like that.
But the not in with you.
Right.
You know,
so it's like,
hey man,
fucking settle down.
It was neat.
I think it was because I hadn't even
talked with that person for months and
months and it didn't even lead with you.
Good man.
Then the joke,
it was just out of nowhere to joke and
the last text was like six months prior.
It was like,
do you
think that person is funny?
Yeah.
Real funny.
Did it talented?
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
You don't like them as a person?
Maybe
annoying.
Slightly.
I don't,
I haven't.
I haven't hung out with them in years,
but yeah,
I don't know.
I could this,
this time and a place for everything.
Yeah.
Laid up
in the hospital is different.
It really depends on who it is,
man.
It just depends on some.
That's uh,
that's one of those fine lines where the
right person can send you that you'd be
laughing your ass off,
but the wrong person could send you
that.
He'd be like,
fuck this dude.
I'm not talking to this guy in the game
anymore.
I don't think anybody sending you that.
You'd be upset like a Byron Bauer sent
you that you'd be upset.
Uh,
I think in that situation I'd be upset
maybe afterwards talking shit,
maybe talk,
I guess context,
right?
I mean,
yeah,
that's all one time about a
went out once I got a tweet when I was
like,
I don't know why I checked my twitter
right before bed.
There's one time it was me and my girl
was about to crash out and I for sorry,
I'll check my twitter and it was a good
show at the comedy cellar.
You got fat though and I was like
right before I'm out to fucking fuck my
girlfriend,
you get fat.
If I was at the bar and I just happened
to check it,
I'm like,
ah,
you get fat.
I'm like,
fuck off.
But right before bed,
man,
this is rough time for that.
So I think it is timing and timing is
everything I might burn.
I don't think they meant it in malicious
with it,
but that shit was like really?
I'm drugged up in the hospital bit in
South Carolina of all places.
Oh,
another detail that happened when,
because this is,
it was coming into my 29,
30.
So I think it was 2012 or 20 anyway,
uh,
so Aziz finds that he comes to the
hospital so and so he's there and so
it's like nurses and shit,
like,
holy shit,
Aziz Ansari.
And he's like,
can you chill out with my friend is if
people are like,
can I take a picture with you?
I love your work.
Is like,
you need to worry about this work right
here.
This TV showed the Hannibal buress just
get his shit smashed show where people
will.
They will legitimately fanning out over
Aziz over my hospital bed.
It was super unprofessional.
Yeah.
That's not nice.
How fucked up were you?
Like were you,
uh,
did you have.
They'd have like,
you want those Halos?
They have your head?
Not In the halo but my,
I was fucked up my,
this,
my forehead.
This was,
I had a few stitches here.
Still got the scar from that.
Uh,
and a skull was fractured.
Skull was fractured right here.
I think it was [inaudible] I was wearing
glasses and the glasses went into here.
Whoa.
But uh,
like how bad is a fraction?
They have to do anything.
No,
it was just like,
just let it,
let it a heel.
Let it heal on.
It's on your head.
Yeah,
he can't put it in Canada.
Probably if you,
if you want to pay for that.
We want to pay extra iron man cast.
So yeah,
we have to push back production on.
Um,
I think that was going into first season
of Eric Andre Show,
so we have to push back production
because my face was all fucked up for
while.
Yeah.
It was a pretty gnarly waking up on a
stretcher.
Yeah.
That's got to be a bizarre feeling.
It was.
I don't remember.
Do you think about that when you get in
cars now are getting cars,
do you think?
I mean that's a,
that's a pretty significant.
I don't think.
I don't really.
I didn't know.
I don't think about occasionally,
but I don't think about that.
What?
What happened?
Who?
Who caused the accident?
I couldn't tell you man.
I couldn't tell you.
I couldn't even know.
I don't know.
Wow.
They're missing some missing chunk of
time.
Just something missing.
Chunk of time.
Fucking head injuries.
Snow.
It was no fun.
Yeah,
that's scary shit.
Yeah.
Bury the hatchet with your friend.
I think so grown up lately.
You're growing up growing up,
man.
Trying to be nicer,
more positive.
That's one thing about being more
recognizable is that it gives me a
constant opportunities to work
my social skills
that's fun.
Like,
oh,
I fucked it up with that person.
That was weird,
so let me.
What did I learn to be more?
Giving people more energy,
be positive to people it can help to.
Also it's.
It takes a little time to recognize that
they're going to have a different
feeling about you than you have about
them to get them to you.
They're a person that you've never met
them,
but to them meeting you is all.
It's weighted a lot of weight to it,
a lot of gravity to the moment and
sometimes people just get overwhelmed by
it and they they fuck up and stumble and
then they call you a monkey and screen
matcha and fucking crazy bitch.
Well,
I think I stopped doing it.
I stopped correcting people that call me
by character names.
Oh,
I used to do that.
I used to be that dude I used to be
because I do the show broad city,
probably my most popular character and
people will say,
hey,
Lincoln
and I used to do that.
No Lincoln as a character that play name
was Hannibal.
I used to be that like that and I'm just
like,
fuck it,
Lincoln.
It is.
Just say hi.
Hey,
what's up?
High doing.
Yeah,
it's tricky man.
The learning how to navigate the waters
of people knowing you and you don't know
them.
And then also alcohol,
you know,
you're out when they recognize you and
they're drunk.
I remember,
uh,
I met this a fucking God damn it.
This guy has been in a million movies.
I'm trying to remember his name,
but I met him once.
It's probably good that I won't say his
name,
I don't remember his name,
but I met him at one of those.
Um,
you know,
they have those press junket things they
do where they have NBC as like all their
talent and all the.
Yeah,
one of those fucking things.
And reporters are wandering around.
They have,
they interview people when you're
drinking and they do it.
Pasadena,
Pasadena.
Yeah.
And I was going on,
on the,
on the hallway to the bathroom and I ran
into this dude and I've seen him in a
100 movies and everything like that.
And I was like,
what's up man?
How you doing it?
What are you doing here man?
And I remember he was like,
yeah,
a world working and he walked by me and
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm an idiot.
It just,
I just,
I just dorked out
drunk and you know,
and he didn't respond the way I thought
he was gonna.
He responded like I'm a Dork,
drunk dork and that was the right way to
do it.
But I remember thinking,
man,
I got to be aware if someone ever does
that to me.
Like how?
Because this is a feeling when you see
somebody that's been in movies before
and you're like fuck,
and you know,
just,
it's just a lesson.
No,
definitely.
I try to
be more appreciative in this dismissive,
you know,
being a comic too.
Is it like constant mocking thing going
on?
But you got it,
you do have to turn it off sometimes,
or at least if not,
turn it off.
Turn it down to to,
to,
to mild,
mild friendly life lessons with Hannibal
buress.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I gotTa wrap this pitch up.
Bring it home.
What do you got going on?
Man?
It's anything you promoting Netflix,
special comedy comma,
Sido February fifth.
When it's common.
Sato mean Casado means a military attack
that occurs at night.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Where did you film this field?
Did in Minneapolis at the,
uh,
at the varsity theater.
How big was that place?
Is places great holds about 500.
600 people.
Um,
that's a good sign.
Yeah.
Says the ceiling.
Uh,
have those high.
Is it a high CEO?
It was,
I,
this is my sweatiest special bar.
I was a super sweaty,
so people don't think I was working.
Art I,
that's a good size though.
500 seats because I wanted to kind of,
I,
instead of doing just two shows,
I did six shows total.
Oh,
just to get comfortable in a venue
that's smart.
And then film the last two.
So I was there Thursday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday in Minneapolis and it was dead
then by the end of the week it felt like
a,
just a club Gig.
Right,
right,
right.
In a bigger spot in a club Gig.
But it was,
it was loose,
let loose.
But it was just a,
it was a weird thing is that
I think most times,
at least in my experience,
uh,
the second show is usually the better
show.
This one,
the first show,
knocked it out of the park it in the
second show was weird.
We probably only used two or three
minutes from the second show.
Really?
Everything else is from the first show.
Wow.
Yeah.
But it was good and I'm,
I'm excited about it.
Excited at the other two specials in
Chicago.
Animal furnace would be on Netflix also.
And uh,
yeah man,
thanks for having me again.
Anytime brother.
And this was,
this was fun.
Always.
Anytime you've got an open invitation.
Yeah.
Just Holler,
man.
Come on by.
I forgot another gas you could sit in
and just talk shit in the background.
Do whatever the fuck want,
man.
You're Hannibal
verse.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it.
That's it for the whole fucking week.
It's over.
Bitches will be back next week.
A lot of entertaining guests.
I'll fill you in with details later,
but I got some good guests next week.
All right,
see Ya.
Bye.